You made a deal when times were tough When what you had was not enough Your wings were clipped, your mouth was dry 1973. A psychiatric hospital. A man walks up to admissions. I hear voices, he says. What do they say? asks the psychiatrist. Empty. Hollow. Thud. He's immediately admitted, diagnosed with schizophrenia, and then kept for weeks. But here's the thing, he's not insane, he's a psychologist. Part of David Rosenhand's experiment to prove that psychiatric diagnosis is bullshit.
你曾在困境中做过交易，当拥有的东西不足以支撑时，你的翅膀被剪断，口干舌燥。1973年，一家精神病院。一名男子走向入院处。他说，我听到了声音。精神科医生问，它们说了什么？空虚、空洞、砰。他立即被收治，被诊断为精神分裂症，并被关押了数周。但问题是，他并没有疯，他是一位心理学家。这是大卫·罗森汉实验的一部分，旨在证明精神病学诊断纯属胡扯。
Eight pseudo-patients, all admitted, all labeled insane for hearing three words, empty, hollow, thud. Those three words would empty, hollow, thud. Those three words would become the perfect description of what American psychology was about to become. 1960s, the computer revolution begins, and with it a seductive new metaphor. The mind itself is a computer. Before we invented architecture, and then God became an architect, then we invented clocks and became... He became a watch maker and now He is the computer itself. The thing that can not only be programmed,
八名伪病人，全部被收治，全部因为听到了“空虚、空洞、砰”这三个词而被贴上精神病的标签。这三个词将成为美国心理学即将变成什么的完美描述。20世纪60年代，计算机革命开始，随之而来的是一个诱人的新隐喻。大脑本身就是一台计算机。在我们发明建筑之前，上帝是建筑师；后来我们发明了时钟，祂变成了钟表匠；现在，祂就是计算机本身。那个不仅可以被编程，
but programmed. The mind that can make itself. Inputs and outputs. Programs and bugs. Hardware and software. Suddenly consciousness isn't mysterious anymore, it's just information processing and it's just information processing that we can debug like any code. Enter Aaron Beck, disillusioned Freudian. He looks at the messy mystical world of psychoanalysis, all that unconscious stuff, all those dreams, all those symbols, all that money, all that talking,
而且可以自我编程的东西。那个可以塑造自我的大脑。输入和输出。程序和漏洞。硬件和软件。突然间，意识不再神秘，它只是信息处理，而且是可以像代码一样进行调试的信息处理。亚伦·贝克登场，一位幻灭的弗洛伊德主义者。他审视着精神分析那混乱而神秘的世界，那些潜意识的东西、那些梦境、那些象征、那些金钱、那些喋喋不休，
that is very hard to turn into something that a hospital can provide as a service oriented industry and he says, what if we just didn't? What if depression isn't about recessed or repressed trauma or archetypal struggles? What if it's just bad code? CBT is born the mind as Microsoft Windows. Your thoughts are programs. Your depression is a bug. Here's your patch. Track negative thoughts, rate them 1 through 10, replace with positive thoughts, and then reboot. Like Microsoft Windows, CBT works about as well. Beck developed a streamlined approach that zeroed in on cognitive distortions as he called them. Catch yourself thinking I'm a total loser and then you can replace it with, I have talents and abilities. Thought by thought,
这些很难转化为医院作为服务导向型行业所能提供的服务，于是他说，如果我们不这样做呢？如果抑郁症不是关于压抑的创伤或原型斗争呢？如果它只是糟糕的代码呢？CBT（认知行为疗法）诞生了，大脑就像微软Windows系统。你的想法是程序。你的抑郁是漏洞。这是你的补丁。追踪负面想法，给它们打分（1到10分），用正面想法替换，然后重启。就像微软Windows一样，CBT的效果也差不多。贝克开发了一种精简的方法，专注于他所谓的“认知扭曲”。当你发现自己在想“我真是个彻头彻尾的失败者”时，你可以用“我有天赋和能力”来代替。一个想法接一个想法，
belief by belief, you debug your operating system without any of the messy subjective interpretation of Freudian analysis or the mysticism of Jung, or the inherent relationship that Carl Rogers or Virginia Satir were proposing as people as parts of systems. You just go in and you say, in CBT, what is it that is the problem? How big is that problem? And then how do I get rid of it? Which assumes that you know what the problem is before CBT begins. When you get rid of it, you do that in an assessment. There is no more Freud telling you that you're double, triple, secret, super gay, and then that's the reason why you don't even know how gay you are. why you don't even know how gay you are. Instead, you just look at all of these different tracking
一个信念接一个信念，你调试着你的操作系统，而无需弗洛伊德分析中那些混乱的主观解读，无需荣格的神秘主义，也无需卡尔·罗杰斯或弗吉尼亚·萨提亚所提出的作为系统一部分的人际关系。你只需进入CBT，问：问题是什么？问题有多大？然后我该如何摆脱它？这假设了你在CBT开始之前就知道问题是什么。当你摆脱它时，你是在评估中完成的。再也没有弗洛伊德告诉你，你是双重、三重、秘密的超级同性恋，而这就是你甚至不知道自己有多同性恋的原因。相反，你只是看着所有这些不同的追踪
software, you know, worksheets that say, first it was an 8, now it is a 7, then it was a 3, now it is a 0. We are done with therapy. Reducing everything down to a number becomes something that's incredibly easy to study because research, especially objective research, doesn't like the messiness of qualitative technique either. It likes to present things as right or wrong, true or false, and CBT offers academia a pathway into this way of understanding the mind, and about verifying what is effective when we treat it. CBT was the psychological equivalent of the coding revolution in software. Just as programmers were learning to write cleaner code, CBT offered a systematic way to refactor buggy mental algorithms. Study after study showed its effectiveness as drugs for depression and anxiety also showed effectiveness. Academic medicine mixed them together. You get six to twelve sessions of CBT and if it doesn't work then you need
软件，你知道，那些工作表上写着：起初是8分，现在是7分，然后是3分，现在是0分。我们完成了治疗。将一切简化为一个数字变得非常容易研究，因为研究，尤其是客观研究，也不喜欢定性技术的混乱。它喜欢把事物呈现为对或错、真或假，而CBT为学术界提供了一条理解大脑的途径，以及验证我们治疗效果的途径。CBT是软件编码革命的心理学等价物。正如程序员学习编写更简洁的代码一样，CBT提供了一种系统化的方法来重构有漏洞的心理算法。一项又一项研究显示了它的有效性，正如治疗抑郁和焦虑的药物也显示出有效性一样。学术医学将它们混合在一起。你接受六到十二次CBT治疗，如果没用，那么你需要
medicine and then hopefully the medicine works because that's your last stop and it's all that insurance is going to pay for. It's genius, it's clean, it's testable, it's also complete horseshit. But it's measurable horseshit and that's all that matters. I had a professor who gave me a CBT study in graduate school and The person was measuring how much weed they were smoking the joint had just gotten bigger but he went from ten joints to one it was just a huge joint and in the same way that the Reagan Revolution and Thatcher's insistence that we now needed government to be accountable and show
药物，希望药物有效，因为那是你的最后一站，也是保险公司唯一愿意支付的费用。这很天才，很简洁，可测试，但也完全是胡扯。但这是可衡量的胡扯，而这才是最重要的。我在研究生院时，一位教授给了我一项CBT研究，那个人在测量他抽了多少大麻，那根烟卷变大了，但他从十根烟卷变成了一根，那只是一根巨大的烟卷。同样地，里根革命和撒切尔夫人坚持认为政府现在需要负责，并展示
the cost benefit on a spreadsheet of everything that we were socializing turns academic testing in schools into basically like this metric that would then control funding and figure out if kids were actually learning in a school if they were getting something out of it. Adam Curtis talks about this a little bit in some of his films, namely all watched over by machines of loving grace. But when you have 20 to 30 years to look at what was actually happening, it wasn't that when you apply objective metrics to something like a hospital that it improves, it's that they reclassify things.
我们在社会化的一切事物的成本效益电子表格，将学校的学术测试基本上变成了某种指标，用来控制资金，并判断孩子们在学校里是否真的在学习，是否从中得到了什么。亚当·柯蒂斯在他的几部电影中稍微谈到了这一点，即《全知之眼》。但当你用20到30年的时间来观察实际发生的事情时，你会发现，当你对医院之类的事物应用客观指标时，情况并没有改善，而是他们重新分类了事物。
In one case, hospitals reclassified chairs as beds and then said, now no one's waiting because everyone has a bed. True story. Academic, the point of this isn't to deconstruct the Reagan and Thatcher kind of revolutions of the way the government and tax worked, but this demanding an objectivity for everything that we used to view as self-evident,
在一个案例中，医院将椅子重新分类为床，然后说，现在没有人等待了，因为每个人都有床。真实故事。学术界，这点的意义不在于解构里根和撒切尔那种政府和税收运作方式的革命，而是这种对我们曾经视为不言自明、
as important, as human, as good, is something that is part of a greater project of reviewing and revivifying our idea of consciousness, of the mind, of government, of systems as just computers. Processes of information, not people, not relationships, not anything intangible. Tanya Lerman is an anthropologist who actually bothered to look at what was happening and she documented something that nobody else wanted to admit. American psychiatry had split into two armed camps and they hated each other. On one side you had psychoanalysts and then they were talking about dreams and transference and
重要、人性、美好的一切事物所要求的客观性，是重新审视和重振我们关于意识、大脑、政府、系统作为计算机这一理念的更大工程的一部分。是信息处理过程，而不是人，不是关系，不是任何无形的东西。坦尼娅·勒曼是一位人类学家，她真正去观察了正在发生的事情，并记录了一些没人愿意承认的事实。美国精神病学分裂成了两个武装阵营，他们互相憎恨。一边是精神分析学家，他们谈论梦境、移情和
the unconscious and they were seeing patients as whole human beings with stories, contexts, and meanings. On the other hand you had the biomedical boys who were pushing the biomedical model and were sort of true believers in this remaking mental health. The brain was a meat computer, mental illness was a chemical imbalance, 15-minute med checks were all the psychiatrist needed to tell you what drug you were gonna take probably for the rest of your life. Symptoms became error codes. Lerman spent years embedded in psychiatric training programs which error codes. Lerman spent years embedded in psychiatric training programs which let her watch this civil war play out and the psychodynamic residents would
潜意识，他们将病人视为拥有故事、背景和意义的完整人类。另一方面是生物医学派，他们推行生物医学模型，某种程度上是这种重塑心理健康的忠实信徒。大脑是一台肉体计算机，精神疾病是化学失衡，15分钟的药物检查就是精神科医生告诉你余生可能要服用什么药物所需的全部。症状变成了错误代码。勒曼花了几年时间深入精神科培训项目，这让她观察到了这场内战的展开，心理动力学住院医生会
sneer at the pill pushers. The biological psychiatrist would mock the fuzzy-minded analysts because they were willing to sit with a fuzzy math of gray area and subjectivity in the room. To the biomedical model, if you check these boxes then you have this condition. And it doesn't really matter that even though the biomedical model has advanced a whole lot, neurology and cognitive science, the things that we directly know about the brain
嘲笑那些推销药丸的人。生物精神科医生会嘲笑那些头脑模糊的分析师，因为他们愿意坐在房间里处理模糊的数学、灰色地带和主观性。对于生物医学模型来说，如果你勾选了这些框，那么你就有这种疾病。尽管生物医学模型已经取得了很大进步，神经学和认知科学，即我们直接了解的大脑知识，
are proving it wrong. It still is seeking ways to validate itself. For example, if you go to Taproot, if you go to our QAEG brain mapping lab, we know that there are six things that can happen in the brain that result in the diagnosis, because the same behavior of ADHD.
正在证明它是错误的。它仍然在寻求验证自身的方法。例如，如果你去Taproot，如果你去我们的QAEG大脑测绘实验室，我们知道大脑中可以发生六种导致诊断结果的事情，因为多动症（ADHD）的行为表现是一样的。
We know that these six different things respond to the same medications, but that doesn't make them the same condition, even when you make it a completely empirical model where you're doing a map of the brain. So here's the kicker. Lerman wanted to watch what they did, not what they said. And something fascinating emerged when she was studying the quote-unquote pure CBT therapists who were treating everyone the same. The therapist itself became a computer. There was no way to do CBT in different ways. You did it right or wrong. The patient said this,
我们知道这六种不同的情况对相同的药物有反应，但这并不意味着它们是同一种疾病，即使当你把它变成一个完全经验性的模型，对大脑进行测绘时也是如此。所以关键在于。勒曼想观察他们做了什么，而不是他们说了什么。当她研究那些治疗所有人方式相同的所谓“纯CBT”治疗师时，一些迷人的东西出现了。治疗师本身变成了一台计算机。没有办法以不同的方式进行CBT。你做得对或错。病人说了这个，
if you followed the model then you said that. It was a way to turn the therapist into a computer so that we didn't have to worry about people quote-unquote doing it wrong. These therapists though, Lerman saw that they were unconsciously doing depth work. They were building relationships, they were holding space, they were using intuition. All the stuff that they said was unscientific were the mechanism of action that they were doing that worked. Why? Because you can't really actually extract a hundred years of psychodynamic wisdom from the cultural water supply. These therapists had absorbed Freud and Jung and Rogers through osmosis. They thought they were doing CBT and they said they were doing CBT but watch them work. They're doing perennial philosophy and CBT drag. The old-timers who'd been trained in
如果你遵循模型，那么你就说了那个。这是一种将治疗师变成计算机的方法，这样我们就不必担心人们“做错了”。然而，勒曼看到这些治疗师在无意识地进行深度工作。他们在建立关系，他们在保持空间，他们在运用直觉。所有他们声称不科学的东西，正是他们正在做的、有效的行动机制。为什么？因为你无法真正从文化水源中提取一百年的心理动力学智慧。这些治疗师通过渗透吸收了弗洛伊德、荣格和罗杰斯。他们以为自己在做CBT，他们说自己在做CBT，但观察他们的工作。他们是在用CBT的外壳做永恒哲学。那些在
psychoanalytic institutes, even if they had converted to CBT for insurance reasons, they still had the moves and they could still read the room, they could still feel into silence, they could still use their mirror neurons, they could track the unconscious stance between the therapist and the client. They were thinking in terms of projections, even if they were talking in the language of CBT. And they just had to call it cognitive restructuring in order to get paid. But here's where someone like Adam Curtis would zoom out and show you the horror.
精神分析学院受过训练的老派人士，即使为了保险原因转而使用CBT，他们仍然掌握着技巧，仍然能读懂房间里的气氛，仍然能感受到沉默，仍然能使用他们的镜像神经元，他们能追踪治疗师和客户之间潜意识的舞蹈。他们是在用投射的角度思考，即使他们说的是CBT的语言。他们只是不得不称之为“认知重构”才能拿到报酬。但这就是像亚当·柯蒂斯这样的人会拉远镜头向你展示恐怖的地方。
What happens when those old timers retire? By the 1990s, the new generation of therapists is being trained in pure CBT and no psychodynamic theory. They don't even remember it, and a lot of them don't know what it is. So there's no depth psychology, no understanding of transference, projection, the unconscious, just worksheets and thought records. And these kids don't even know what they don't know. They've never heard of object relations. They think parts work as woo woo. They believe that the mind really is a computer, even though it isn't when they start to tell you about their politics or what church they go to.
当那些老派人士退休后会发生什么？到了20世纪90年代，新一代治疗师接受的是纯CBT培训，没有心理动力学理论。他们甚至不记得它，许多人根本不知道它是什么。所以没有深度心理学，没有对移情、投射、潜意识的理解，只有工作表和思维记录。这些孩子甚至不知道他们不知道什么。他们从未听说过客体关系。他们认为部分工作（Parts Work）是伪科学。他们相信大脑确实是一台计算机，尽管当他们开始告诉你他们的政治观点或他们去哪个教堂时，事实并非如此。
And their therapy? Empty, hollow, thud. The replication crisis would later prove what everyone else already knew. Most of what made therapy work couldn't be measured. The studies showing CBT's effectiveness? They were accidentally measuring the psychodynamic skills that the therapist didn't know that they were using or couldn't write that they were. And when you strip those skills out, when you train a generation of therapists who really do only CBT, the effectiveness plummets
而他们的治疗呢？空虚、空洞、砰。复制危机后来证明了其他人早已知道的事情。大多数让治疗有效的东西是无法测量的。那些显示CBT有效性的研究？它们无意中测量了治疗师自己都不知道在使用、或者无法写出来的心理动力学技能。当你剥离这些技能，当你培养出一代真正只做CBT的治疗师时，有效性就会暴跌，
because it turns out you can't debug a soul, and you can't worksheet your way out of existential terror, and you can't thought record yourself into wholeness. And when these guys retired, all of a sudden the studies, when you had a generation of people that were taught that CBT was the gold standard of research, all of a sudden stopped working. There was a mental health crisis, mental health outcomes got better, psychiatric hospitals stopped working, but they doubled down on doing CVT because they had been told that it was the gold standard, even though the current research that wasn't 20 years old was showing that CVT
因为事实证明你无法调试灵魂，你无法通过工作表摆脱存在主义的恐惧，你无法通过思维记录让自己变得完整。当这些人退休时，突然间，那些研究——当你有一代人被教导CBT是研究的黄金标准时——突然停止了工作。出现了心理健康危机，心理健康结果变好了，精神病院停止工作了，但他们加倍投入CBT，因为他们被告知这是黄金标准，尽管不是20年前的当前研究显示CBT
became less effective every year. But let's back up. Why did America want therapy to become empty? What did they get out of this deal? If you go back to something like Eric Spern's games, in the game that we were playing, what was the unconscious reward that America got? The Boomers had made a deal with the devil. They'd inherited a world shaped by their parents' war trauma, nuclear family isolation, white flight and suburbanization, women entering the workforce with no children, communities destroyed for highways, real systemic stuff, and the kind of analysis that might lead to uncomfortable questions like, maybe capitalism is making us crazy, maybe the nuclear family is this historic anomaly that when you inject it with the profit motive, makes people insane. But boomers didn't want systemic analysis, they wanted individual solutions, and they wanted to believe that if you just fixed your thinking, then you would be fine.
每年都在变得不那么有效。但让我们退一步。为什么美国希望治疗变得空虚？他们从这笔交易中得到了什么？如果你回到像埃里克·伯恩的《游戏》之类的东西，在我们玩的游戏中，美国得到的潜意识奖励是什么？婴儿潮一代与魔鬼做了交易。他们继承了一个由父母的战争创伤、核心家庭孤立、白人群体外迁和郊区化、女性进入劳动力市场而没有孩子、社区为高速公路而毁灭、真正的系统性问题所塑造的世界，以及那种可能导致令人不安的问题的分析，比如：也许资本主义让我们发疯了，也许核心家庭是一个历史性的反常现象，当你给它注入利润动机时，它让人发疯。但婴儿潮一代不想要系统性分析，他们想要个人解决方案，他们想相信如果你只是修正了你的思维，那么你就会没事的。
If you just pulled up your bootstraps, then you would be okay. Never mind that you're working 60 hours a week with no community support, while your kids are being raised by TV and the drug epidemic becomes the medication for trauma that is what most people under 30 are using. CBT was perfect for this. Your depression isn't about living in an insane society, it's about a cognitive distortion. Your anxiety isn't about a precarious employment and no healthcare. You just need to challenge those negative thoughts. It put the onus of control
如果你只是靠自己努力，那么你就会没事的。别管你每周工作60小时而没有社区支持，当你的孩子由电视抚养长大，而毒品流行成为大多数30岁以下的人用来治疗创伤的药物时。CBT对此非常完美。你的抑郁不是关于生活在一个疯狂的社会中，而是关于认知扭曲。你的焦虑不是关于不稳定的就业和没有医疗保险。你只需要挑战那些负面想法。它把控制的责任
back on the individual almost entirely when our real environmental and emotional life is a reciprocal force that moves backwards and forwards in between an objective and a subjective world. Some of the things that government was supposed to provide as its part of the bargain it increasingly failed to provide for younger generations. But America wanted to be over identified with individual responsibility, rational thought, quick fixes, measurable outcomes. America was under-identified with community, emotion, mystery, depth, time, relationship. Something that like a society obsessed with these things
几乎完全放回了个人身上，而我们真实的环境和情感生活是一种在客观世界和主观世界之间来回移动的相互作用力。政府本应作为其交易的一部分提供的一些东西，却越来越多地未能提供给年轻一代。但美国希望过度认同个人责任、理性思维、快速修复、可衡量的结果。美国对社区、情感、神秘、深度、时间、关系认同不足。像一个痴迷于这些东西的社会
inherently becomes myopic because what happens is that emotion isn't important when it's other people's. It's only important when it's mine. CBT gave them exactly what they wanted, a therapy that reinforced all their over-identifications while ignoring everything that they were actually avoiding. Adam Curtis told... In one of Adam Curtis' films, he shows John Nash creating game theory,
本质上会变得近视，因为发生的事情是，当情感是别人的时，它就不重要了。只有当它是我的时，它才重要。CBT给了他们想要的，一种强化了他们所有过度认同，同时忽略了他们实际上正在逃避的一切的疗法。亚当·柯蒂斯告诉……在亚当·柯蒂斯的一部电影中，他展示了约翰·纳什创造博弈论，
the story that's also told from one angle in the movie A Beautiful Mind, and this mathematical model where everything is rational and every actor is maximizing self-interest through rational action. That's what John Nash publishes that gets him the Nobel Prize. The Cold War military loves it and so do economists that believe that everyone is rational actors except for when they go to the dinner party and they start talking about their wife and their barber and all the people at their church and all of the people in their office who can't manage money that are completely irrational.
这个故事在电影《美丽心灵》中也从一个角度讲述了，这是一个数学模型，一切都是理性的，每个参与者都通过理性行动最大化自身利益。这就是约翰·纳什发表并获得诺贝尔奖的内容。冷战时期的军方喜欢它，相信每个人都是理性行为者的经济学家也喜欢它，除了当他们去参加晚宴，开始谈论他们的妻子、理发师、教堂里的所有人以及办公室里所有无法理财、完全非理性的人时。
Yet the kinds of theories that they're developing about the mind and the broader economics based on it assumes that everybody is this rational actor a hundred percent of the time. That there's no other forces out there that move society, that move anything, that forces out there that move society, that move anything, that change the things that we buy. I personally don't buy a triple Applebee's cheeseburger when my bank account is low because I don't know that I don't have money.
然而，他们正在发展的关于大脑和基于此的更广泛经济学的理论，假设每个人百分之百的时间都是这种理性行为者。没有其他力量在外面推动社会，推动任何事情，改变我们购买的东西。我个人在银行账户余额不足时不会去买三层苹果蜂芝士汉堡，并不是因为我不知道我没钱。
It's just that I kind of want the burger. Curtis argues that this mechanistic view had unintended consequences. Nash's ideas conceived as modeling rational decision-making were being co-opted by military planners to justify viewing the world as a brutal zero-sum competition between self-interested actors who were meeting out the most dominant style of government, of family, of self. But Nash himself came to realize that such models grossly oversimplified human motives. His
只是因为我有点想吃那个汉堡。柯蒂斯认为，这种机械论的观点产生了意想不到的后果。纳什的思想被设想为模拟理性决策，却被军事规划者利用，以证明将世界视为自私行为者之间残酷的零和竞争是合理的，这些行为者正在制定政府、家庭、自我的最主导风格。但纳什本人后来意识到，这种模型极大地简化了人类的动机。他的
own model was something that Nash later threw out. People aren't always rational utility maximizers. They're driven by emotions, moral values, social bonds that defy the pure interests of logic. Nash's own struggles with mental illness revealed the mind as a far more fragile and unpredictable than elegant game theory equations allowed. But Nash's theories didn't just warp military strategy and economic policy, they reshaped psychology itself. The mind was reconceived as a logic engine, an optimization machine.
自己的模型是纳什后来抛弃的东西。人们并不总是理性的效用最大化者。他们受到情感、道德价值观、社会纽带的驱动，这些都违背了纯粹的逻辑利益。纳什自己与精神疾病的斗争揭示了大脑比优雅的博弈论方程所允许的要脆弱和不可预测得多。但纳什的理论不仅扭曲了军事战略和经济政策，它们还重塑了心理学本身。大脑被重新构想为逻辑引擎、优化机器。
Emotion became noise, meaning became error. The prefrontal cortex, the so-called rational brain, was ground king. And yet when Nash's game the so-called rational brain, was ground king, and yet when Nash's game theory was tested on actual humans, it broke down every time. Take the gangsters dilemma, a variation of the prisoners dilemma or the infamous money and the diamond experiments, where suppose players were going to follow Nash's logic. Maximize your gain, minimize your loss. But over and over people didn't act rationally. They trusted when they shouldn't and they got punished when it hurt them. They gave away wealth, they lied, they cooperated, they withheld, or they acted from spite or intuition. In one experiment,
情感变成了噪音，意义变成了错误。前额叶皮层，所谓的理性大脑，是基础之王。然而，当纳什的博弈论在真实人类身上进行测试时，它每次都崩溃了。以“黑帮困境”为例，这是囚徒困境的一个变体，或者是臭名昭著的“金钱与钻石”实验，假设玩家会遵循纳什的逻辑。最大化你的收益，最小化你的损失。但人们一次又一次地没有表现得理性。他们在不该信任的时候信任了，在受伤时受到了惩罚。他们放弃了财富，他们撒谎，他们合作，他们隐瞒，或者他们出于恶意或直觉行事。在一个实验中，
people were given a diamond and money and they were supposed to exchange it with somebody, but they had to have an element of trust in order to make the exchange. Well, Nash's prediction was that people would act self-interestally, that even though it was dishonest, they would take the money and the diamond because that was what provided the least risk and the optimal outcome for them. In reality, no one behaved this way. Everyone allowed an element of trust into their life in order to make the exchange like had been agreed in the scenario they were given. In other words, they acted human. Even under lab conditions, with real stakes, Nash's elegant predictions failed to describe actual behavior. And that failure wasn't a fluke.
人们得到了一颗钻石和钱，他们应该和某人交换，但他们必须有一种信任元素才能完成交换。好吧，纳什的预测是人们会表现得自私，即使这不诚实，他们也会拿走钱和钻石，因为那是风险最小、结果最优的选择。实际上，没有人这样做。每个人都在生活中允许了一种信任元素，以便像给定的场景中商定的那样进行交换。换句话说，他们表现得像个人。即使在实验室条件下，在有真实赌注的情况下，纳什优雅的预测也未能描述实际行为。而那种失败并不是偶然。
It was a flashing red light. The human mind is not a machine built for logic. We're not spreadsheets. We're not algorithms. We are narrative making, grief haunted, and hope driven animals. So just as CBT had floundered when it tried to reduce suffering to faulty thoughts, game theory collapsed when it tried to reduce humanity to equations. It turns out that you can't build a model of a mind that leaves out the soul. You can't worksheet your way through abandonment. you can't optimize your way out of despair. What you can do is tell people that suffering is normal and that they should white-knuckle it for life, which is cruel and medieval.
那是一个闪烁的红灯。人类大脑不是为逻辑而构建的机器。我们不是电子表格。我们不是算法。我们是叙事制造、被悲伤困扰、被希望驱动的动物。所以，正如CBT在试图将痛苦简化为错误想法时陷入困境一样，博弈论在试图将人性简化为方程时也崩溃了。事实证明，你无法构建一个忽略灵魂的大脑模型。你无法通过工作表度过遗弃。你无法通过优化摆脱绝望。你能做的是告诉人们痛苦是正常的，他们应该咬牙坚持一生，这既残忍又中世纪。
You can't game theory your way into love. And you can't put the value of trust on a spreadsheet. When a civilization forgets this, it amputates depth, mystery, relationship, myth, and it doesn't become more rational, it becomes more lost. Soon everyone has to use CVT, including psychologists. Eric Byrne takes game theory and he creates transactional analysis. He writes the book, The Games People Play, that becomes incredibly meteoric at a time when people are obsessed with, well, you know, the post-Froidian thing, the Cold War, and Nick John Nash's game theory, but also a lens to look under the hood in a way that
你无法通过博弈论进入爱情。你无法把信任的价值放在电子表格上。当一个文明忘记了这一点，它就切断了深度、神秘、关系、神话，它并没有变得更理性，而是变得更迷失。很快每个人都必须使用CBT，包括心理学家。埃里克·伯恩采用博弈论并创造了交互分析。他写了《人们玩的游戏》一书，在人们痴迷于——嗯，你知道，后弗洛伊德主义、冷战和约翰·纳什的博弈论——的时代，这本书变得非常流行，但也提供了一个透视引擎盖下的视角，
CBT won't let them go in therapy in the pop culture. Every interaction is this strategic calculation. Every relationship is a game with winners and losers. We're not humans losers. We're not humans anymore. We're players running problems, maximizing utility. But the roots of Freudian analysis were dormant in the Eric Burns book. He's using ego states. He's using unconscious motivations. But he's trying to provide a circuit diagram or logical, you know, conceptual way to identify
CBT在流行文化中不会让他们进入治疗。每一次互动都是这种战略计算。每一段关系都是一场有赢家和输家的游戏。我们不再是人类了。我们是运行问题的玩家，最大化效用。但弗洛伊德分析的根源在埃里克·伯恩的书里是休眠的。他使用自我状态。他使用潜意识动机。但他试图提供一个电路图或逻辑的、你知道，概念性的方法来识别
what someone's doing in a way that becomes successful for them because real people can apply it and put it on their coffee table. But also it becomes a way that the depth tradition can continue to remain in the public consciousness without threatening the profit motive in medical healthcare. The models were wrong. Humans aren't computers. We'd already rebuilt society and psychology on the assumption that we were. And by the 1980s, the computational metaphor has conquered almost everything.
某人在做什么，以一种对他们成功的方式，因为真实的人可以应用它并把它放在咖啡桌上。但这也成为深度传统可以在公众意识中继续存在，而不威胁医疗保健利润动机的一种方式。模型错了。人类不是计算机。我们已经基于我们是计算机的假设重建了社会和心理学。到了20世纪80年代，计算隐喻几乎征服了一切。
Economics, humans are rational, utility maximizers, politics, voters are predictable algorithms that we just need more micro-target targeted data in order to manipulate and improve. We can make them believe anything that we want. Mines are in psychology, minds are computers to be programmed and it's society's conception of itself. We are a vast network of interconnected nodes. The DSM-3 arrives nearly 500 pages of checklists. It is a response to the question that Rosenbaum opens up. It is an answer to people like R.D. Lange that are saying things like, you're not crazy. Being feeling crazy is a normal response to inhabiting a crazy world. The world should change a little bit to meet your mental health. Not your mental health should be adapted
经济学，人类是理性的，效用最大化者；政治，选民是可预测的算法，我们只需要更多的微目标数据来操纵和改进。我们可以让他们相信我们想要的任何东西。心理学中的大脑，大脑是需要编程的计算机，这是社会对自身的构想。我们是一个巨大的互联节点网络。DSM-3（精神疾病诊断与统计手册第三版）问世，近500页的检查清单。它是对罗森汉开启的问题的回应。它是对像R.D.莱恩这样的人的回应，他们说的是：你没疯。感到疯狂是对居住在一个疯狂世界中的正常反应。世界应该改变一点以满足你的心理健康。而不是你的心理健康应该被调整
to fit into any world that we demand you have to fit into. Any hole that we carve out is something that it is your job to fill. All of this pushback is taken away, and the DSM-3 walks back on all of the promises that the DSM-1 and 2 made about how this manual would never be used for diagnosis in a biomedical type model, that it would never be used for something like insurance billing, on and on and on.
以适应我们要求你必须适应的任何世界。我们挖出的任何洞都是你的工作去填补。所有这些反击都被拿走了，DSM-3收回了DSM-1和2关于这本手册永远不会用于生物医学模型诊断、永远不会用于保险账单等所有承诺。
All of those things are thrown away and it becomes a very different book. Just symptoms that you can count. Mental illness as error codes and checklists that tell you what is happening with unconsciousness, even if they don't really. Rosenhand's study, along with the broader anti-psychiatry movement, contributed to this growing crisis of confidence in psychiatric diagnosis, as it should have, and in the 1970s this skepticism was one of the big influences on the DSM-3's radical overhaul by 1980. Operationalized criteria, observable symptoms, attempts at diagnostic reliability.
所有这些东西都被扔掉了，它变成了一本非常不同的书。只是你可以计算的症状。精神疾病作为错误代码和检查清单，告诉你潜意识里发生了什么，即使它们并没有真正做到。罗森汉的研究，连同更广泛的反精神病学运动，导致了这种对精神病学诊断日益增长的信心危机，正如它本应发生的那样，在20世纪70年代，这种怀疑论是DSM-3在1980年进行彻底改革的影响因素之一。操作化的标准、可观察的症状、对诊断可靠性的尝试。
And we didn't really care if they were right. We cared if they were reliable. We didn't care if they were helpful. We just needed something sort of consistent. Insurance companies loved it and researchers loved it. The only people who didn't love it was anyone who was actually suffering. Because trauma doesn't compute, pain doesn't process, the unconscious doesn't run on Windows 95. Here's the thing that Lerman noticed that nobody wanted to talk about.
我们并不真正关心它们是否正确。我们关心它们是否可靠。我们并不关心它们是否有帮助。我们只需要某种一致的东西。保险公司喜欢它，研究人员也喜欢它。唯一不喜欢它的是任何真正受苦的人。因为创伤无法计算，痛苦无法处理，潜意识不在Windows 95上运行。这是勒曼注意到但没人想谈论的事情。
Even as CBT conquered everything, the good therapists kept doing depth work. They just had to lie about it, maybe even to themselves. Watch a skilled CBT therapist work. I refer to a lot of them. I don't hate the model because I know that a lot of the people who do it aren't actually bad therapists. The model is just another piece of an incentive structure that pushes most therapists to go the wrong direction. When you watch a talented CBT practitioner, they're tracking their relationship. They're noticing what's being said. They're aware of the parental sometimes, but in other ways the projection that they hold of a broader society, of a broader world. They're feeling into the emotional field. They're holding
即使CBT征服了一切，优秀的治疗师仍在进行深度工作。他们只是不得不对此撒谎，甚至可能对自己撒谎。观察一位熟练的CBT治疗师的工作。我推荐很多这样的人。我不讨厌这个模型，因为我知道很多做它的人实际上并不是糟糕的治疗师。这个模型只是激励结构中的另一部分，推动大多数治疗师走向错误的方向。当你观察一位有才华的CBT从业者时，他们正在追踪他们的关系。他们注意到正在说什么。他们有时意识到父母的影响，但在其他方面，他们持有对更广泛社会、更广阔世界的投射。他们正在感受情感领域。他们正在保持
paradox. They're sitting with mystery. A lot of times while they sign an insurance contract that says that they won't do any of these things because they're not evidence-based. And they'll write in their notes, challenge cognitive distortion regarding worthlessness. But what actually happened was a moment of profound human connection where someone felt seen for the first time in their life. And the research on mechanisms of action actually backs this up. When you analyze what creates change in therapy, it's often the relationship, not the technique, the therapist's capacity to hold complexity, not their theoretical orientation's description of it, the client
悖论。他们正在与神秘共处。很多时候，当他们签署一份保险合同时，上面写着他们不会做任何这些事情，因为它们不是基于证据的。他们会在笔记中写道：“挑战关于无价值感的认知扭曲”。但实际上发生的是一种深刻的人类连接时刻，某人一生中第一次感到被看见。关于行动机制的研究实际上支持了这一点。当你分析是什么在治疗中创造了改变时，通常是关系，而不是技术；是治疗师保持复杂性的能力，而不是其理论取向对它的描述；是客户
feeling understood, not having their thoughts corrected intellectually. The very things that CBT claims don't matter are the only things that actually matter in the room, and CBT is simply existing around them, or those things are existing around CBT. Fast forward to the 2010s. The replication crisis hits psychology like a meteor. It turns out that most of our scientific findings are bullshit. The landmark CBT studies can't replicate. The effectiveness? Full of publication bias, pee hacking, and wishful thinking. But here's the darker truth. The replication crisis reveals that we'd been
感到被理解，而不是在智力上被纠正想法。CBT声称不重要的东西正是房间里唯一重要的东西，而CBT只是存在于它们周围，或者那些东西存在于CBT周围。快进到2010年代。复制危机像陨石一样击中了心理学。事实证明，我们的大部分科学发现都是胡扯。具有里程碑意义的CBT研究无法复制。有效性？充满了发表偏倚、P值操纵和一厢情愿。但这里有一个更黑暗的真相。复制危机揭示了我们一直
accidentally measuring the wrong things all along. The first generation of CBT studies showing effectiveness. The therapists were all trained in psychodynamic therapy first and they were doing depth work and calling it CBT. Of course it worked. They were doing actual therapy. But the new studies with the new therapists trained only in CBT and trained by therapists that had only been trained in CBT, are they're disasters. Because it turns out that when you really do just CBT, just the worksheets, just the thought challenging, just the behavioral activation, it doesn't work. And you know what? The same things that have worked before continue to. Being heard, being seen, having your pain witnessed, making meaning from suffering, connecting with another human being, being taught that your abnormal experience is actually
无意中测量了错误的东西。第一代CBT研究显示了有效性。治疗师们首先都接受过心理动力学治疗培训，他们正在做深度工作，并称之为CBT。当然它有效。他们正在做真正的治疗。但那些只接受过CBT培训、并由只接受过CBT培训的治疗师培训的新治疗师所做的新研究，简直是灾难。因为事实证明，当你真正只做CBT，只做工作表，只做思维挑战，只做行为激活时，它是不起作用的。你知道吗？以前有效的东西继续有效。被倾听，被看见，你的痛苦被见证，从苦难中创造意义，与另一个人连接，被教导你的异常经历实际上
normal in a long enough timeline and with enough context for how we think. The perennial philosophy of therapy. The things that every culture discovered independently. The things we keep forgetting and rediscovering. philosophy of therapy, the things that every culture discovered independently, the things we keep forgetting and rediscovering. And meanwhile, in reality, Carter's crisis of confidence speech, 1979, imagination and optimism of the 60s hadn't really panned out. All the hippies were on harder drugs and had failed to integrate into society or fundamentally
在足够长的时间线和足够多的背景下是正常的。治疗的永恒哲学。每个文化独立发现的东西。我们不断忘记又重新发现的东西。治疗的哲学，每个文化独立发现的东西，我们不断忘记又重新发现的东西。与此同时，在现实中，卡特的信心危机演讲，1979年，60年代的想象力和乐观主义并没有真正实现。所有的嬉皮士都在吸食更硬的毒品，未能融入社会，也没有从根本上
change anything material about the way the culture worked. Carter's speech is broadly rejected because it had and immediately rejected at the time because it is trying to ask America to have a different myth about itself. It's trying to ask people if maybe we should stop worrying and aspire to more than credit card debt, than eating red meat, than Monopoly house and cheap consumer goods. And it wanted you to challenge this monopoly on empire, but Americans wanted a monopoly on empire, as all empires do.
改变文化运作方式的任何实质性东西。卡特的演讲被广泛拒绝，因为它是——在当时被立即拒绝，因为它试图要求美国对自己有一个不同的神话。它试图问人们，也许我们应该停止担心，并渴望比信用卡债务、吃红肉、大富翁房子和廉价消费品更多的东西。它想让你挑战这种帝国垄断，但美国人想要帝国垄断，正如所有帝国所做的那样。
It wanted ego to have a monopoly on the mind, as all egos do. And the work of self-discovery was tossed aside as boring and irrelevant. The peak oil crisis, or the oil embargo ends, and things can just go back to normal. America doesn't want to hear about spiritual malaise. Reagan gives them simple answers. You're not spiritually empty. You just need tax cuts. You need more money. You're not traumatized. You just need to work harder.
它想要自我对大脑拥有垄断权，正如所有自我所做的那样。而自我发现的工作被当作无聊和无关紧要的东西抛弃了。石油危机，或者石油禁运结束了，事情可以恢复正常。美国不想听到精神上的萎靡不振。里根给了他们简单的答案。你不是精神空虚。你只是需要减税。你需要更多的钱。你没有受到创伤。你只是需要更努力地工作。
You're playing the victim. You're not systemically oppressed. You're just wrong. We don't need environmental regulations because the planet is this resilient thing that we should go ahead and use up in your lifetime. It doesn't really matter what happens later. Don't think about it. Well, the crisis of confidence speech is one of the only, probably to this day only, addresses to the nation that really asks people to challenge a prevailing myth and ask them to look inward and ask them to aspire to more. Now we're sort of pulled by an algorithm that feeds us back everything that they think that we want to hear with different results. Psychology has always had to dance to the era's prevailing metaphors and as the Cold War rages on and computers become more
你在扮演受害者。你没有受到系统性的压迫。你只是错了。我们不需要环境法规，因为地球是一个有弹性的东西，我们应该在你的一生中继续使用它。以后发生什么并不重要。别去想它。好吧，信心危机演讲是为数不多的，可能至今唯一一次真正要求人们挑战流行神话，要求他们向内看，要求他们渴望更多的国家演讲。现在我们被一种算法所牵引，它用不同的结果把我们认为想听的一切反馈给我们。心理学一直不得不随着时代的流行隐喻而起舞，随着冷战的持续和计算机变得越来越
ubiquitous, information processing and computational theory sort of win the metaphor of the paradigm of the day. But the real problems haven't gone away. There's a divorce epidemic. There's latchkey kids. There's Vietnam PTSD coming home. There's women entering the workforce. And who's going to watch children? And what does this mean for this myth that we've sold of what the family looks like. Communities are fragmenting, drugs are going up, the CIA is kind of running cocaine, but who's noticing that anymore or remembering it five minutes later? There's real trauma, there's real systemic violence, but there's no language to describe it left. We deleted all of those files. And here's what CBT revolutionaries never understood. You can't dismantle psychoanalysis using psychoanalytic wisdom. Every effective CBT
无处不在，信息处理和计算理论在某种程度上赢得了当天的范式隐喻。但真正的问题并没有消失。离婚流行病。钥匙儿童。越南战争创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）回家。女性进入劳动力市场。谁来照顾孩子？这对我们兜售的家庭样貌的神话意味着什么？社区正在碎片化，毒品正在增加，中央情报局（CIA）在某种程度上在经营可卡因，但还有谁注意到这一点，或者五分钟后还记得它？有真正的创伤，有真正的系统性暴力，但已经没有语言来描述它了。我们删除了所有这些文件。这就是CBT革命者从未理解的。你无法使用心理动力学智慧来拆除精神分析。每一位有效的CBT
therapist is unconsciously doing psychodynamic work, but they're using transference. You just don't name it. You're holding an environment, but you call it a therapeutic frame. You're using containment, but now you call it boundaries. You're using interpretation, but you're calling it psychoeducation. You're working through what's called homework, but you're changing these things to be something that fundamentally can't replace what they actually are. And so the outcomes of therapy are going to get worse because the people who are in the middle levels of insight, the middle levels of talent, aren't being given incentive structures to make them reach the upper levels, to make them get better. People are incentivized to get worse. And not everyone is always going to be terrible, but those incentive
治疗师都在无意识地进行心理动力学工作，但他们在使用移情。你只是不命名它。你正在保持一个环境，但你称之为治疗框架。你正在使用包含，但现在你称之为边界。你正在使用解释，但你称之为心理教育。你正在通过所谓的家庭作业来解决问题，但你正在把这些东西变成从根本上无法取代它们本来面目的东西。因此，治疗的结果会变得更糟，因为那些处于洞察力中层、才华中层的人，没有被给予激励结构来让他们达到更高水平，让他们变得更好。人们被激励去变得更糟。并不是每个人总是会很糟糕，但那些激励
structures do push most people into certain directions. And so at the same time that we're talking about the economic motivations that rule society and treating people like incentive structures around money and secular systems and material are the only thing that motivate them, we're also pretending that those things don't matter in psychology. They're speaking psychoanalysis with a CBT accent, these therapists that are still left in the profession in the 70s, and it works until you train people who only speak CBT and then they fundamentally cannot talk to real people anymore. So these new generation of therapists have no idea why their therapy doesn't work. They follow the manual perfectly, they
结构确实将大多数人推向了特定的方向。因此，当我们谈论统治社会的经济动机，并将人们视为仅仅受金钱、世俗体系和物质激励结构驱动的个体时，我们同时也假装这些东西在心理学中并不重要。那些在70年代仍留在该行业的治疗师们，用CBT（认知行为疗法）的口吻说着精神分析的话，这在他们训练出只会说CBT的人之前是有效的，而一旦训练出来，他们就从根本上无法再与真实的人交流了。所以，这些新一代的治疗师根本不知道为什么他们的疗法不起作用。他们完美地遵循手册，他们
assign the homework, they take more classes, they hang more pieces of paper on their wall that's a certification proving why they're smart, and they challenge thoughts and their clients don't get better. Because they're trying to fix something that isn't broken and they're trying to debug a system that isn't a computer and they're trying to solve something that isn't a problem. It's a human being having an emotional experience in an inhumane world. Or maybe they're missing what the real problem actually is, which is why psychology becomes such a punching bag that so many people start to distrust more and more. It couldn't even actualize the problem that they were bringing into the room because
布置家庭作业，参加更多的课程，在墙上挂更多的证书来证明自己很聪明，他们挑战客户的想法，但客户并没有好转。因为他们试图修复的东西并没有坏，他们试图调试的系统不是计算机，他们试图解决的问题根本不是问题。这是一个在非人道世界中经历情感体验的人。或者也许他们忽略了真正的问题所在，这就是为什么心理学变成了众矢之的，以至于越来越多的人开始对其产生怀疑。它甚至无法实现他们带入咨询室的问题，因为
that problem had to be an issue that they could fix by white-knuckling it through emotion and not noticing these real problems in the world are somehow becoming bigger than them instead of becoming part of a process that might have changed some of those things. You know Jung said that if you ignore the shadow it returns as monsters and all that trauma, all that unconscious material, all that systemic suffering. Where does it go when you pretend that it doesn't exist? It comes back as Satan. There's two groups that converge. There's the second-wave feminists that are starting to do early and good somatic psychotherapy.
那个问题必须是一个他们可以通过强行压抑情感来解决的问题，而不是注意到世界上这些真正的问题正变得比他们自身更大，而不是成为可能改变其中一些事情的过程的一部分。你知道荣格说过，如果你忽视阴影，它就会以怪物的形式回归，所有的创伤、所有的潜意识材料、所有的系统性苦难。当你假装它们不存在时，它们去了哪里？它们以撒旦的形式回来了。有两个群体汇合了。第二波女权主义者开始进行早期且良好的躯体心理治疗。
And they're finally naming child abuse, something that Freud failed to do. They're starting to believe the children and they're breaking generations of silence about things like patriarchy and the systemic nature of people who run the world that pretend to be good but actually do horrible things beneath the scenes. The second group that they ally with that are pretty different from them are conservative Catholics. They're reeling from Vatican II, Latin Mass is gone,
他们终于指出了虐待儿童的问题，这是弗洛伊德未能做到的。他们开始相信孩子们，并打破了关于父权制以及那些统治世界的人的系统性本质的几代沉默，这些人表面上装作善良，但在幕后却做着可怕的事情。他们与之结盟的第二个群体与他们截然不同，那就是保守派天主教徒。他们正因第二次梵蒂冈大公会议而感到震惊，拉丁弥撒消失了，
they're looking for proof that Satan is real, and they're also angry that this thing that is supposed to be unchanging and part of the conservative culture and hierarchy is now different. But they agree on one thing, the children are being hurt. And so Lawrence Paster, he's a psychiatrist, he's sleeping with his patient while married to a different person who he later divorces, he marries
他们正在寻找撒旦真实存在的证据，他们也对这种本应是不变的、属于保守文化和等级制度的一部分现在却变得不同而感到愤怒。但他们在一件事上达成了共识：孩子们正在受到伤害。于是劳伦斯·帕兹德（Lawrence Paster），他是一位精神科医生，他在与另一人结婚期间与自己的病人发生性关系，后来他离婚了，并娶了
his patient while he's sleeping with the patient that he's still doing therapy on who has DID, Dissociative Identity Disorder, he says that he's recovering all of these memories of satanic ritual abuse through some hypnotic technique that he uses. And these memories are that hundreds of Satanists in Victoria, in Canada, and underground tunnels, and there's babies being sacrificed nightly underneath these major cities all throughout North America, and that sometimes the Virgin like intervenes spiritually to stop people. You know this stuff should have been laughed out of the room but instead he becomes the expert. You know he trains the police, he consults on the McMartin abuse cases, he even becomes a household name. You know so many people have that book. He's on the news multiple times talking about how like Satan comes out of records and that we
他的病人，同时还在与他正在进行治疗的另一位患有DID（解离性身份障碍）的病人发生性关系。他说他通过自己使用的一种催眠技术恢复了所有关于撒旦仪式虐待的记忆。这些记忆显示，在加拿大维多利亚市的地下隧道里，有数百名撒旦崇拜者，在北美各大城市之下，每晚都有婴儿被献祭，有时圣母玛利亚会从精神上干预以阻止人们。你知道这些东西本应被嘲笑出局，但他却成了专家。你知道他培训警察，为麦克马丁（McMartin）虐待案提供咨询，甚至家喻户晓。你知道很多人都有那本书。他多次出现在新闻中，谈论撒旦如何从唱片中出来，以及我们
need to take that seriously in mental health. Because even scientists need an explanation for what's wrong and a literal Satan is easier than we build a society that runs on trauma and then we made trauma illegal to discuss through the means that we're supposed to analyze it, through the psychology that was supposed to be in conversation with why we are sick. We didn't cure sickness, we ended the conversation by making sickness illegal and we removed all the lenses that people could use to see mental illness. So guess what? I guess we're healed. This computational metaphor creates these two problems during this. Everything has to be rational, but humans aren't. And everything has to be conscious except trauma isn't.
需要在心理健康方面认真对待这一点。因为即使是科学家也需要对错误的原因做出解释，而一个字面意义上的撒旦比我们建立一个基于创伤运行的社会更容易解释，然后我们通过本应分析它的手段——即本应与我们为何生病进行对话的心理学——使讨论创伤变得非法。我们没有治愈疾病，我们通过使疾病非法化结束了对话，并移除了人们用来观察精神疾病的所有透镜。所以猜猜怎么着？我想我们被治愈了。这种计算隐喻在此过程中产生了这两个问题。一切都必须是理性的，但人类不是。而且一切都必须是意识到的，但创伤不是。
So when real abuse survivors come forward there's this messy fragmented somatic memory. A lot of times they're drugged, a lot of times they're children, a lot of times they just weren't making memory in the way that we think about memory like it's this videotape where we can recall things. We are running on memory all of the time without remembering exactly what happened 20 years ago. We are this sort of embodied experience. There's multiple types of memory. And so Satan becomes this stand-in.
所以当真正的虐待幸存者站出来时，会有这种混乱、碎片化的躯体记忆。很多时候他们被下药，很多时候他们是孩子，很多时候他们只是没有以我们认为记忆的方式形成记忆，就像我们可以回溯事情的录像带一样。我们一直在依靠记忆运行，而不需要准确记住20年前发生了什么。我们是这种具身经验。记忆有多种类型。所以撒旦成了这个替身。
The Satanic Panic was CBT's shadow. It both tried to simplify the unsimplifiable and it let us avoid the real depths of self But here's what nobody talks about. Why did set therapy seem to work better in the past? It's not nostalgia It's training a therapist trained in 1960, you know studied Freud even if they rejected him. They understood transference They knew about projection. They had their own analysis. They understood the unconscious. They could hold paradox They could fundamentally understand what trauma was in a way that somebody trained in CVT was not able to. They might practice CVT, but they had the depth psychology in their bones and they could feel when something else was happening in the room. They had what someone like Wilfred Bayon would call a negative capability.
撒旦恐慌是CBT的阴影。它既试图简化不可简化的东西，也让我们避免了自我的真正深度。但没人谈论的是：为什么过去治疗似乎更有效？这不是怀旧。这是训练。1960年受训的治疗师，即使他们拒绝弗洛伊德，也研究过他。他们理解移情。他们知道投射。他们有自己的分析。他们理解潜意识。他们能容纳悖论。他们能从根本上理解什么是创伤，而受过CBT训练的人却无法做到。他们可能练习CBT，但他们的骨子里有深度心理学，他们能感觉到咨询室里发生了别的事情。他们拥有威尔弗雷德·比昂（Wilfred Bion）所说的“消极能力”。
The ability to remain uncertain without the irritability caused by a therapist who is trained to think that they have to understand everything logical all the time, that their intuition is a distraction and not a tool. And so a therapist trained in the 2000s, you know, they learned six weeks on CBT, two weeks on medication, insurance billing codes, evidence-based protocols, manualized treatments, and zero depth or somatic training, unless they got maybe a mindfulness class or something that Lenahan snuck in through the back door in one of the modules of DBT. They don't even know what they're missing and they never feel the uncanny presence of the unconscious in their room and they've
即在没有烦躁的情况下保持不确定性的能力，这种烦躁是由那些被训练认为必须时刻理解所有逻辑事物的治疗师引起的，他们认为直觉是一种干扰而不是工具。所以2000年代受训的治疗师，你知道，他们学习了六周的CBT，两周的药物治疗，保险账单代码，循证协议，手册化治疗，以及零深度或躯体训练，除非他们可能上过正念课，或者莱恩汉（Linehan）在DBT模块中通过后门塞进来的东西。他们甚至不知道自己错过了什么，他们从未在咨询室里感受到潜意识的诡异存在，而且他们
never had their own depth records explored. You know, they're trying to guide others through territory that they've never even visited and if the patient brings it up they're very likely to get overwhelmed or angry. It's like teaching swimming from a textbook when you've never been in the water. And here's what nobody admits. Lawrence Paster and Aaron Becker are kind of the same person. They both need a certainty. They both fear the depths. They both promise simple answers to complex problems. You know, Paster is Catholic and and to him the reason that the world is changing is because Satan is in charge of it. And this evangelical bent kind of enters the Catholic
从未探索过自己的深度记录。你知道，他们试图引导别人走过他们自己从未去过的领地，如果病人提出来，他们很可能会感到不知所措或愤怒。这就像在从未下过水的情况下通过教科书教游泳。没人承认的是：劳伦斯·帕兹德和亚伦·贝克（Aaron Beck）其实是同一种人。他们都需要确定性。他们都害怕深度。他们都承诺用简单的答案解决复杂的问题。你知道，帕兹德是天主教徒，对他来说，世界正在改变的原因是撒旦在掌管它。这种福音派倾向进入了天主
church that it's not that you go to church to commune with God, it's that God has abandoned the world and the material world and the political and social systems that inhabit it are fundamentally flawed and bad so you should be suspicious of everything that you interact with and hate it. But when things look good, you have to sort of invent that there's Satanists that are like underneath the world doing these things. Where Beck is saying problems in your thinking are errors, there's a right way to think and there's a wrong way and that you can just find each bug and correct it. But there's a black and whiteness that appeals to the same people even though a lot of the implications, you know, of these systems of thought would be very
教会，即你不是为了与上帝交流而去教堂，而是上帝已经抛弃了世界，物质世界以及居住在其中的政治和社会体系从根本上是有缺陷和邪恶的，所以你应该对你接触的一切持怀疑态度并憎恨它。但当事情看起来不错时，你必须编造出世界之下有撒旦崇拜者在做这些事。而贝克则说你思维中的问题是错误，有正确的思考方式和错误的思考方式，你可以找到每一个漏洞并纠正它。但这种非黑即白的思维吸引了同样的人，尽管这些思想体系的许多含义会非常
different. But both are saying don't look at systems, don't feel your feelings, don't trust your body, trust our method, our method is perfect and it can be replicated completely perfectly again and again and again. And watch how the same people bounce between extremes. You know there's fundamentalists that become militant atheists, there's New Age healers who convert to pure CBT or vice versa. There's the satanic panic who becomes, you know, the satanic panic, you know, ritual abuse therapist who all of a sudden becomes this advocate for false memories and that this is all made up. But there's very few people that have an ability to understand both parts of the mind. They just start doubling down on one and then when reality becomes unbearable,
不同。但两者都在说：不要看系统，不要感受你的情绪，不要相信你的身体，相信我们的方法，我们的方法是完美的，它可以一次又一次地被完全完美地复制。看看同样的人如何在极端之间跳跃。你知道有变成激进无神论者的原教旨主义者，有皈依纯CBT的新时代治疗师，反之亦然。有撒旦恐慌，你知道，撒旦恐慌仪式虐待治疗师突然变成了虚假记忆的倡导者，说这一切都是编造的。但很少有人有能力理解心灵的两个部分。他们只是开始加倍投入其中一个，当现实变得无法忍受时，
they switch to something that lets them avoid the same fear with a completely different belief system. You know, evangelicals who platform pastor, they're still reeling from Vatican too, if they're Catholic, if they're not, they already have this kind of fear of emotion that fits very well with the Protestant evangelical American church and they're desperate to prove that Satan is real, so God must be too. So if we find evidence of Satan, that brings us proof of God. And they're clinging to certainty, any certainty. The devil made me do it means that I don't have to look at why I do the things that I don't know and
他们就转向某种能让他们用完全不同的信仰体系来避免同样恐惧的东西。你知道，为帕兹德提供平台的福音派，如果他们是天主教徒，他们仍然对第二次梵蒂冈大公会议感到震惊；如果不是，他们已经有了这种对情绪的恐惧，这与新教福音派美国教会非常契合，他们迫切地想证明撒旦是真实的，所以上帝也一定是。所以如果我们找到撒旦的证据，那就给我们带来了上帝的证据。他们紧紧抓住确定性，任何确定性。“魔鬼让我这么做”意味着我不必去审视我为什么做那些我不知道和
understand. If there is an actual literal devil that came out of records or potions or culture or the news or something and then made these things happen, we don't have to look at the forces that actually make us do things that are a lot or rational, illogical, that we don't like, that we don't understand. And we sure as shit can't change them because they're not my action. Somebody made me do it who's not me. So like I bear no responsibility in the change process. So it's the same way that these sort of things start to blame the victim. You know, everyone else has victim mindset.
不理解的事情。如果有一个真正的魔鬼从唱片、药水、文化、新闻或其他什么东西里出来，然后导致了这些事情发生，我们就不必去审视那些实际上让我们做一些我们不喜欢、不理解的、非理性的事情的力量。而且我们肯定无法改变它们，因为那不是我的行为。是别人让我做的，不是我。所以我对改变过程不承担任何责任。所以这和这些事情开始责怪受害者的方式是一样的。你知道，每个人都有受害者心态。
Everybody else doesn't want to change, only I do. You're doing the same thing by saying the devil is doing it or that emotion or the trauma is somehow not real or not relevant. And the CBT zealots who worship evidence-based practice, they're doing the same thing. They're clinging to their randomized controlled trials like their rosary beads so that they can pretend that they're doing it the right and the perfect way and they don't have to sit with anything that could be better, anything that could be different, other than just more training to get this new technique like it's Freemasonry or something, and you take the next degree. They're not ideas that could be
其他人都不想改变，只有我想。你说魔鬼在做这件事，或者情绪或创伤在某种程度上是不真实的或不相关的，你也在做同样的事情。而崇拜循证实践的CBT狂热分子也在做同样的事情。他们像拿着念珠一样紧紧抓住他们的随机对照试验，这样他们就可以假装自己是以正确和完美的方式在做，他们不必面对任何可能更好、任何可能不同的东西，除了更多的训练来获得这种新技巧，就像它是共济会或其他什么东西，你获得下一个学位。它们不是可以
integrated into you and applied, because you don't have to change as a person. You just have to collect more qualifications. That means that you have these experience points. Not that you would go out and engage with something and then learn about it and then change as a person, and that might make you change as a provider. The CBT zealots who worship you know this evidence-based practice stuff, you know, and the Lawrence Pazder satanic panic people, they're saying don't feel, don't go deep, stay on the surface where it is safe. Because when you start to really listen to the metaphors that these people are coming up with during the satanic panic, they are just that.
整合到你身上并应用的思想，因为你不需要作为一个人去改变。你只需要收集更多的资格证书。这意味着你有这些经验点。而不是你会走出去与某事互动，然后了解它，然后作为一个人改变，这可能会让你作为一个提供者发生改变。崇拜这种循证实践的CBT狂热分子，你知道，还有劳伦斯·帕兹德的撒旦恐慌人群，他们都在说：不要感受，不要深入，留在安全的地表。因为当你开始真正倾听这些人在撒旦恐慌期间提出的隐喻时，它们就是隐喻。
They're metaphors for sexual abuse a lot of the time. Ones that Pazder can't hear. He can't say, oh, this is an image that the mind made because it felt like this. He has to literally believe that half of Toronto is like going into the subway to sacrifice babies instead of looking at the fact that these people are sexually abused in their families of origin and this stuff is extremely common and then it's covered up and then we have very little accountability and some of the perpetrators are some of the most powerful people who run our society. When you turn something into a satanic cult, you don't have to ask hard questions about society and so because of that the satanic panic
它们很多时候是性虐待的隐喻。帕兹德听不到的隐喻。他不能说，哦，这是一个心灵创造的意象，因为它感觉是这样的。他必须字面意义上地相信多伦多有一半人像是在进入地铁去献祭婴儿，而不是去审视这些人是在原生家庭中受到性虐待的事实，这种事情极其普遍，然后被掩盖了，然后我们几乎没有问责，而一些施暴者正是统治我们社会的最有权势的人。当你把某事变成撒旦崇拜时，你就不必问关于社会的尖锐问题，所以正因为如此，撒旦恐慌
hard questions about society. And so because of that, the satanic panic functions in a way that is very similar to the CBT revolution. It lets us avoid the same emotion and it lets us stay enmeshed with the same emotions that we want to hold on to. It lets us keep the hero myth. It lets us keep the belief that we are these sort of logical creatures that have to move forward without having to move inward. And these people get exactly what they're looking for. You know, children describe these impossible tunnels, these flights to Mexico, you know, baby breeding and harvesting of farms. The therapists believe it because they need to believe it. The parents believe it because they need an explanation for why their child is distressed without having to accept a reality that is more horrible.
关于社会的尖锐问题。正因为如此，撒旦恐慌的功能与CBT革命非常相似。它让我们避免了同样的情绪，让我们保持与我们想要坚持的同样情绪的纠缠。它让我们保留了英雄神话。它让我们保留了我们是那种必须向前迈进而不必向内探索的逻辑生物的信念。而这些人得到了他们想要的东西。你知道，孩子们描述这些不可能的隧道，这些飞往墨西哥的航班，你知道，婴儿繁殖和农场收获。治疗师相信它，因为他们需要相信它。父母相信它，因为他们需要一个解释，说明为什么他们的孩子会痛苦，而不必接受一个更可怕的现实。
You don't really want it to be Mr. Connor who is your friend. You don't really want it to be the pastor of your church. It's all that easier to believe that it's demons or people in black robes, not someone that you know. And so the prosecutors believe it because they need convictions and nobody ever asks, what if the distress is real but the explanation is metaphorical? Because that would require holding complexity and we've trained that out of everyone.
你真的不希望那是你的朋友康纳先生。你真的不希望那是你教堂的牧师。相信那是恶魔或穿黑袍的人要容易得多，而不是你认识的人。所以检察官相信它，因为他们需要定罪，而且没有人问：如果痛苦是真实的，但解释是隐喻性的呢？因为那需要保持复杂性，而我们已经把这种能力从每个人身上训练掉了。
And the therapist doing recovered memory work are using the same techniques as CVT. They're looking for specific patterns, they're reinforcing correct responses, they're ignoring contradictory evidence, and they're assuming that the theory is right and that the client's is wrong. You're coaching people in order to pass the
而进行恢复记忆工作的治疗师正在使用与CBT相同的技术。他们寻找特定的模式，他们强化正确的反应，他们忽略矛盾的证据，他们假设理论是正确的，而客户是错误的。你在指导人们通过
objective metric that you have decided that measures their distress to prove that they're happy. In the same way that sans standardized testing in schools doesn't yield better results. The kids who come out of the school are getting better on the ACT or whatever and when you actually talk to the people who are employing them or doing their therapy, they're getting worse at all of the things that make them educated, that will make them human. You're changing the test. You're teaching the test with CBT. You're saying, oh, if you don't feel good, do this and then you feel better. Don't you feel better? And the person is getting this message that they're supposed to feel better. And then you're raising their score but you're not really
你决定的衡量他们痛苦的客观指标，以证明他们是快乐的。就像学校里的标准化考试并不能带来更好的结果一样。从学校出来的孩子在ACT或其他考试上表现得更好，但当你真正与雇佣他们或为他们做治疗的人交谈时，他们在所有让他们受过教育、让他们成为人的事情上都在变差。你在改变考试。你用CBT教考试。你说，哦，如果你感觉不好，做这个，然后你就会感觉更好。你感觉好点了吗？而那个人得到的信息是他们应该感觉更好。然后你提高了他们的分数，但你并没有真正
exploring if any of those things are okay. Maybe they have a reason to be angry, maybe they need to reconnect with a voice, maybe they do need to be distressed for a while and in that distress they will find the soul. Whether you're hunting for Satanist or cognitive distortions the method is the same force reality to fit your model. The McMartin trial is that 360 children disclose abuse and the FBI investigates 12,000 cases of ritual abuse and they find absolutely nothing, not a single shred of evidence. But they do find real abuse in homes and churches and schools, regular non-satanic abuse,
探索这些事情中是否有任何是没问题的。也许他们有理由生气，也许他们需要重新连接一个声音，也许他们确实需要痛苦一段时间，而在那种痛苦中，他们会找到灵魂。无论你是在寻找撒旦崇拜者还是认知扭曲，方法都是一样的：强迫现实去适应你的模型。麦克马丁审判是360名儿童披露虐待，联邦调查局调查了12,000起仪式虐待案件，结果什么也没发现，连一丝证据都没有。但他们确实在家庭、教堂和学校里发现了真实的虐待，普通的非撒旦式虐待，
the kind that's always been there, the kind that we built systems to ignore. The satanic panic served its function. It discredited anyone talking about repressed memories, body memories, systemic trauma, one hysteria used to invalidate all depth work. And America was playing a game with itself. And like Curtis's example shows, when you treat life like the prisoner's dilemma, everyone defects, everyone loses. Therapists start competing for insurance billing. Patients compete for diagnoses. They start to identify with diagnoses, which is a crazy thing, and not how psychotherapy is supposed to work. They're not a tribe, they're not a race, they're not a religion. But people get on Instagram and they're proud of this because of the way that we
那种一直存在、那种我们建立系统去忽视的虐待。撒旦恐慌发挥了它的功能。它抹黑了任何谈论压抑记忆、身体记忆、系统性创伤的人，歇斯底里被用来使所有的深度工作无效。而美国在和自己玩一场游戏。正如柯蒂斯（Curtis）的例子所展示的那样，当你把生活当作囚徒困境时，每个人都会背叛，每个人都会输。治疗师开始竞争保险账单。病人竞争诊断。他们开始认同诊断，这是一件疯狂的事情，而不是心理治疗应该有的工作方式。他们不是一个部落，不是一个种族，不是一种宗教。但人们在Instagram上，他们为这一点感到自豪，因为我们
started to do this. And everyone optimizes for the wrong metrics. And the mental health system becomes what Deleuze and Gattari warned about, this machine producing subjectivities that fit the capitalist machine. And every single time that someone tells you CVT is the gold standard, remind them it's the gold standard because it's the only therapy designed to be measured by the tools that we use to measure. It's like saying that hammers are the best tool because they're best at hammer tests. Empty, hollow, thud. What did we lose? We lost the unconscious. We lost the body. We lost systemic thinking. We lost uncertainty. We lost mythology. We lost depth. We lost mystery. We lost time. We lost relationships. And we created a world of machines, except the machines were us and there
开始这样做的方式。每个人都在为错误的指标进行优化。心理健康系统变成了德勒兹（Deleuze）和加塔利（Guattari）所警告的那样，这台机器生产出适合资本主义机器的主体性。每当有人告诉你CBT是黄金标准时，提醒他们它是黄金标准，因为它只是唯一一种被设计为可以用我们用来测量的工具来测量的疗法。这就像说锤子是最好的工具，因为它们在锤子测试中表现最好。空洞、沉闷的砰声。我们失去了什么？我们失去了潜意识。我们失去了身体。我们失去了系统性思维。我们失去了不确定性。我们失去了神话。我们失去了深度。我们失去了神秘感。我们失去了时间。我们失去了关系。我们创造了一个机器世界，除了机器就是我们，而
was not anything that was healing about them. Because they couldn't contain us, but we kept thinking about them like they were us and us like we were them. And here's what none of these systems can do. They can't work against their own incentive structures. CBT can't say, maybe some problems take years to heal. Insurance won't pay that. Psychiatry can't say, maybe you're sad for good reasons. Pharma won't fund that or its line won't go up. Evangelicals can't say, maybe doubt is holy. Maybe God is found in the mystery because congregations blood pressure will go down. They'll stop viewing life as this fallen emergency that is about to be the end of the world and they won't
它们没有任何治愈作用。因为它们无法容纳我们，但我们一直把它们想成是我们，把我们想成是它们。这就是所有这些系统都做不到的事情。它们无法违背自己的激励结构。CBT不能说，也许有些问题需要几年时间才能治愈。保险公司不会支付。精神病学不能说，也许你难过是有充分理由的。制药公司不会资助，或者它的股价不会上涨。福音派不能说，也许怀疑是神圣的。也许上帝是在神秘中被发现的，因为会众的血压会下降。他们会停止将生活视为一场即将到来的世界末日的堕落紧急情况，他们就不会
tithe. Pastor can't say, maybe these are metaphors, because nobody's gonna buy the book and he's not gonna be allowed on the news. They're all trapped in their own certainty machines. And certainty is just another word for the death of curiosity, which is another word for avoiding growth, which is another word for trauma response.
什一奉献。帕兹德不能说，也许这些是隐喻，因为没人会买这本书，他也不会被允许上新闻。他们都被困在自己的确定性机器中。而确定性只是好奇心死亡的另一个词，也就是避免成长的另一个词，也就是创伤反应的另一个词。
In her research, Lerman found something poignant. The last generation of psychodynamically trained therapists working in community clinics still doing real work. They bill insurance for CBT, they fill out the forms, they use the language, but in the room they were doing what they were trained to do. They were following affect, they were tracking the unconscious, they were holding the frame, they were containing the unbearable, and they were metabolizing the toxic. And above all they were staying curious and assuming that they didn't know everything and weren't doing therapy perfectly which is what allowed them to improve because therapy wasn't a formula that one could do perfectly it was a
在她的研究中，勒曼（Lerman）发现了一些令人心酸的事情。最后一代受过心理动力学训练的治疗师在社区诊所工作，仍在做真正的工作。他们为CBT开具保险账单，他们填写表格，他们使用那种语言，但在咨询室里，他们做的是他们受训要做的事情。他们跟随情感，他们追踪潜意识，他们保持框架，他们容纳不可承受的，他们代谢有毒的。最重要的是，他们保持好奇，并假设他们并不了解一切，并没有完美地进行治疗，这正是让他们能够进步的原因，因为治疗不是一种可以完美执行的公式，它是一个
process of self-discovery yourself and the patient and they're like the secret agents of deaf work in this forgotten depth i talked to somebody informally a couple years ago during this time and she said I felt like I was doing witchcraft during this witch trials when she refused to be a cbt therapist in 1982. And they know that their knowledge will die with them and the young therapists that they supervise don't have the foundation to understand what they're really doing and they're no longer allowing the language in colleges for them to say it. And one old psychiatrist told Lerman, I teach CBT techniques, but I'm really teaching them to pay attention, and once they learn to pay attention, they discover everything else on their own. Which brings me
你自己和病人自我发现的过程，他们就像这场被遗忘的深度工作中的秘密特工。我几年前在这段时间里非正式地和某人谈过，她说当她在1982年拒绝成为CBT治疗师时，我觉得自己就像在女巫审判期间进行巫术。他们知道他们的知识会随他们而去，他们监督的年轻治疗师没有基础去理解他们真正在做什么，而且大学里不再允许他们使用那种语言来表达。一位老精神科医生告诉勒曼，我教授CBT技术，但我实际上是在教他们注意，一旦他们学会了注意，他们就会自己发现其他一切。这让我想到了
to another point. A lot of the things that make therapy work aren't teachable. You can recognize when someone wants to know them and if they can learn them, but you can't really explain them to people who don't know. What happens when there's no one left who knows how to pay attention? Strange bedfellows emerge. You know, there's this computational view of the mind, cold, rational, mechanistic. It finds an unlikely ally in the evangelical movement. James Dobson stands before a focus on the family crowd and he tells them, when your babies cry, don't give them milk, give them water. And that will let them know that you heard them,
另一点。很多让治疗有效的事情是不可教的。你可以识别出什么时候有人想知道它们，如果他们能学会它们，但你真的无法向不知道的人解释它们。当没有人知道如何注意时会发生什么？奇怪的盟友出现了。你知道，这种心灵的计算观，冷漠、理性、机械。它在福音派运动中找到了一个意想不到的盟友。詹姆斯·多布森（James Dobson）站在“关注家庭”（Focus on the Family）的人群面前，他告诉他们，当你的婴儿哭时，不要给他们奶，给他们水。那会让他们知道你听到了他们，
but that they're breaking the rules because they're being hungry when it's not meal time. An infant child, you know, a pre-egoic creature. And the message is, emotion is weakness, control is godliness, shame is discipline. You know, dogs know to nurse their baby when it is crying, when it is an infant, because that is healthy, and that is what's supposed to happen. And we've invented this system of logic and rationalism and control that made human beings at the height of culture forget what dogs know when they're two years old. The idea that emotion is dangerous, that it would lead to sin or lead to illogic or lead to death or whatever room you're in, is this thing that makes you not feel, that makes you part of computation, that just makes you
但他们打破了规则，因为他们在不是用餐时间时感到饥饿。一个婴儿，你知道，一个前自我阶段的生物。而信息是：情绪是软弱，控制是虔诚，羞耻是纪律。你知道，狗知道在婴儿哭的时候给它喂奶，因为那是健康的，那是应该发生的事情。而我们发明了这种逻辑、理性主义和控制系统，使处于文化巅峰的人类忘记了狗在两岁时就知道的事情。情绪是危险的，它会导致罪恶或导致不合逻辑或导致死亡，无论你在哪个房间，这种想法就是让你不感受，让你成为计算的一部分，让你只是
obey. And the same people that are saying we must be logical and empirical, they're on TV saying that the Smurfs were teaching communism and witchcraft. They're saying that Dungeons and Dragons was doing real magic, or that if you played Dungeons and Dragons long enough that you would get a real sword and stab your friend. You know the Misfits, like music, would somehow make kids sacrifice goats when they said like I don't like, I don't know, any Misfits songs but they're like about not liking school. That playing Stairway to Heaven or Backwards would reveal some line about here's my age
服从。而那些说我们必须逻辑和经验的人，他们在电视上说蓝精灵（Smurfs）在教共产主义和巫术。他们说《龙与地下城》（Dungeons and Dragons）在施展真正的魔法，或者如果你玩得够久，你就会得到一把真正的剑并刺伤你的朋友。你知道Misfits乐队，音乐，会以某种方式让孩子们献祭山羊，当他们说，我不喜欢，我不知道，任何Misfits的歌，但它们是关于不喜欢学校的。播放《Stairway to Heaven》或倒着放会揭示出关于“这是我的年龄”的某行歌词
to sweet Satan or something. The Procter and Gamble's logo was satanic symbols. They're people that are very obviously traumatized and very obviously emotional and very obviously motivated by emotion, telling you that emotion isn't real. And no one has the tools left to hear what they're saying or to analyze what they're really saying on TV.
给甜蜜的撒旦之类的。宝洁公司的标志是撒旦符号。他们是非常明显受到创伤、非常明显情绪化、非常明显受情绪驱动的人，告诉你情绪不是真实的。而且没有人剩下工具来听他们在说什么，或者分析他们在电视上真正说的是什么。
We don't listen to how people feel anymore. we listen to what they say and we need to stop. The most scientific era in psychology's history believed that daycare workers could fly children to rituals and hot air balloons. That there were vast tunnels and networks under every preschool that linked together, like the Lord of the Rings, Minds of Moria. They said that babies were being bred in farms for sacrifices to charge up the devil's power level. They said that the MTV logo of a mouth was the logo somehow reflective of a
我们不再倾听人们的感受了。我们倾听他们说的话，我们需要停止。心理学史上最科学的时代相信日托工作者可以把孩子带到仪式上，坐热气球。每个学前班下面都有巨大的隧道和网络连接在一起，就像《指环王》里的摩瑞亚矿坑。他们说婴儿在农场里被繁殖用于献祭，以充能魔鬼的力量水平。他们说MTV嘴巴的标志是某种反映了
real portal to hell that could be opened if you listen to enough music. You know, by the late 1980s there were 12,000 plus cases of ritual abuse investigated by the FBI, there were hundreds of daycare workers arrested, families were destroyed, children were traumatized. Children were coached by the investigators using these techniques. Therapists made fortunes on recovered memories, physical evidence found zero, zero underground tunnels, zero bodies, zero actual Satanists, some confused teenagers with Ozzy albums that were smoking reed. And while America haunted imaginary Satanists, the Catholic Church systematically covered up thousands of real abuse cases. Jeffrey Epstein was building up his network in plain sight with
通往地狱的真实门户的标志，如果你听足够的音乐就能打开它。你知道，到1980年代末，联邦调查局调查了12,000多起仪式虐待案件，数百名日托工作者被捕，家庭被摧毁，儿童受到创伤。孩子们被调查人员使用这些技术进行指导。治疗师在恢复记忆上发了财，物理证据发现为零，零地下隧道，零尸体，零真正的撒旦崇拜者，只有一些听着Ozzy专辑抽着大麻的困惑青少年。当美国人纠缠于虚构的撒旦崇拜者时，天主教会系统性地掩盖了数千起真实的虐待案件。杰弗里·爱泼斯坦（Jeffrey Epstein）在众目睽睽之下建立他的网络，
people who are still in politics and still run the world. The CIA was flooding inner cities with crack cocaine and lying about it. Reagan was funding death squads in Central America. Savings and loan crisis destroyed the middle class. Manufacturing jobs disappeared overseas. Healthcare costs exploded. Education became unaffordable. There was a real satanic network. There were actual demons being born, but people were not looking at the metaphorical. They were looking at the literal and so they were blind. If we gave our entire culture the DSM screener for borderline personality disorder, what happens? Fear of abandonment. If you're not productive, you're worthless. Unstable relationships. A 50% divorce rate and a complete death of community.
那些人仍然在政界，仍然统治着世界。中央情报局正在用快克可卡因淹没内城并撒谎。里根正在资助中美洲的死亡小队。储蓄和贷款危机摧毁了中产阶级。制造业工作岗位流向海外。医疗成本爆炸。教育变得负担不起。有一个真正的撒旦网络。有真正的恶魔在诞生，但人们没有在看隐喻。他们在看字面意义，所以他们瞎了。如果我们给我们的整个文化做边缘性人格障碍的DSM筛查，会发生什么？对被抛弃的恐惧。如果你没有生产力，你就是一文不值。不稳定的关系。50%的离婚率和社区的彻底死亡。
Identity disturbance. Who are we? Are we just our brands, our jobs, our income? Impulsivity. Credit card debt. A news cycle where people can't remember what happened two hours ago. Addiction dimmings. Projection onto political figures like they are
身份障碍。我们是谁？我们只是我们的品牌、我们的工作、我们的收入吗？冲动。信用卡债务。一个人们记不住两小时前发生了什么的新闻周期。成瘾。对政治人物的投射，就像他们是
Marvel superheroes or gods. Suicidal behaviors. Ignoring risks like nuclear war. Emotional instability. Road wage and Twitter mobs and cancel culture. Chronic emptiness. Mental health diagnoses at a sky-high rate. Inappropriate anger. People who can't watch the news without their blood pressure going through the roof. Dissociation. There's screens everywhere.
漫威超级英雄或神。自杀行为。忽视核战争等风险。情绪不稳定。路怒症、推特暴民和取消文化。慢性空虚。精神健康诊断率高得惊人。不适当的愤怒。那些不看新闻就血压飙升的人。解离。到处都是屏幕。
Very often, very seldom do we ever participate in one conversation or one thing. Borderline personality disorder happens when someone can't regulate emotions because they never learned how. And when they can't form stable identity because they were never properly mirrored, and when they split the world into all good and all bad because they can't hold complexity. The same diagnosis, which I don't really love from a book that I don't like, that tells
我们很少参与一次对话或一件事。边缘性人格障碍发生在一个人无法调节情绪时，因为他们从未学会如何调节。当他们无法形成稳定的身份时，因为他们从未被适当地镜像，当他们把世界分裂成全好和全坏时，因为他们无法容纳复杂性。同样的诊断，我并不喜欢那本我不喜欢的书，它告诉你
you how to diagnose borderline personality disorder is actually telling on itself. And that's exactly what we did to our culture. We created a culture that can't tolerate ambiguity, it can't process grief, it can't hold paradox, can't see metaphor, it can't feel without consuming something. It doesn't believe that something is real if there's not an objective metric. It can't think without computing and it can't exist without producing. We gave ourselves cultural BPD and then we acted surprised when everyone started cutting themselves, you know, with credit cards and filling this void with opiates. As the satanic panic peaked, the backlash began. The false memory syndrome
如何诊断边缘性人格障碍，实际上是在揭示它自己。这正是我们对我们的文化所做的。我们创造了一种无法容忍模糊性、无法处理悲伤、无法容纳悖论、无法看到隐喻、不消费就无法感受的文化。它不相信如果没有客观指标，某事就是真实的。它不计算就无法思考，不生产就无法存在。我们给了自己文化上的BPD，然后当每个人开始用信用卡割伤自己，并用阿片类药物填补这个空虚时，我们表现得很惊讶。随着撒旦恐慌达到顶峰，反弹开始了。虚假记忆综合症
foundation, you know, was formed and accused parents started to fight back. Families were torn apart by recovered memories and they start to sue therapists, some win millions. A certain type of the profession loses a whole lot of credibility. Real survivors, you know, get caught in the crossfire and their actual trauma is delegitimized by the hysteria over false memories And the baby legitimate trauma therapy gets thrown out with the satanic bathwater of this culture That largely did not come from psychology
基金会成立了，被指控的父母开始反击。家庭因恢复的记忆而分崩离析，他们开始起诉治疗师，有些人赢得了数百万美元。该行业的某种类型失去了很多信誉。真正的幸存者在交火中被困，他们真实的创伤被对虚假记忆的歇斯底里所否定。而合法的创伤治疗被与这种文化中撒旦式的洗澡水一起倒掉了，这种文化在很大程度上并非来自心理学。
The people who really hurt other people were being co-opted by broader cultural movements that psychology and psychotherapy itself didn't invent. Now, you know, anyone talking about repressed memories has to be wrong. The body containing emotion, that's Satan's stuff. Dissociation is made up. Systemic abuse is a conspiracy theory. The unconscious itself is unscientific. And if you're saying that maybe, maybe we deserve to take a minute
那些真正伤害他人的人正被心理学和心理治疗本身并未发明的更广泛的文化运动所吸收。现在，任何谈论压抑记忆的人都一定是错的。身体包含情绪，那是撒旦的东西。解离是编造的。系统性虐待是阴谋论。潜意识本身是不科学的。如果你说也许，也许我们值得花点时间
and try and rethink the way that we do things so that we could analyze ways to change this world and make it slightly better, you're unreasonable, you're immature, and you're full of victimhood. It is hard to right the boat when it wasn't made to float For so long we let it go, baby down to Cubs. Out with the devil, out with the devil, out with the devil, out with the devil, out with the devil. I'm with the devil. I'm with the devil. I'm with the devil. Geraldo Rivera went on TV in 1995. And he said, we've found no proof of satanic ritual abuse anywhere in the country.
尝试重新思考我们做事的方式，以便我们可以分析改变这个世界并使其稍微好一点的方法，你就是不合理的，你是不成熟的，你充满了受害者心态。当船不是为了漂浮而制造时，很难纠正它。太久了，我们让它随波逐流。打倒魔鬼，打倒魔鬼，打倒魔鬼，打倒魔鬼，打倒魔鬼。我和魔鬼在一起。杰拉尔多·里维拉（Geraldo Rivera）在1995年上了电视。他说，我们在全国任何地方都没有发现撒旦仪式虐待的证据。
And I want to announce publicly that as a firm believer in the believe the children movement, that that movement is now dead. But what really died wasn't just belief in satanic cults, it was trust in memory, it was faith in good therapy, it was a belief in the unconscious, it was an understanding of trauma, and it was any hope of a depth work. We solved the satanic panic by making all depth illegal, by declaring the unconscious unscientific, and by reducing therapy to symptom management. By the mid-1990s, CBT had conquered everything.
我想公开宣布，作为一个“相信孩子”运动的坚定信徒，那个运动现在已经死了。但真正死去的不仅仅是对撒旦崇拜的信仰，而是对记忆的信任，是对良好治疗的信念，是对潜意识的信仰，是对创伤的理解，以及对任何深度工作的希望。我们通过使所有深度工作非法化，通过宣布潜意识是不科学的，通过将治疗简化为症状管理，解决了撒旦恐慌。到1990年代中期，CBT已经征服了一切。
It's the only therapy insurance covers. It's the only approach that gets research funding. It's the only one that speaks the language of research enough to even get research, even if you pay for the research yourself. And it's what they teach in graduate schools. It's evidence-based because we only measure what it measures. And this message is complete. You don't have it unconscious. You have thinking errors. You don't have body memories. You have cognitive distortions. You don't have systemic trauma. You have individual
它是保险公司唯一承保的疗法。它是唯一获得研究资助的方法。它是唯一一种说研究语言足以进行研究的方法，即使你自己支付研究费用。这也是他们在研究生院教的东西。它是循证的，因为我们只测量它所测量的东西。这个信息是完整的。你没有潜意识。你有思维错误。你没有身体记忆。你有认知扭曲。你没有系统性创伤。你有个人
pathology. You don't need depth. You need worksheets. And you don't need time. You need techniques. And you also don't ever need to try and change the world that you live in. You need to realize that your victimhood is something that you should go in and kill all of your capacities for being vulnerable. You don't need community. You need to be able to function as a completely
病理。你不需要深度。你需要工作表。你也不需要时间。你需要技巧。你也不需要尝试改变你所生活的世界。你需要意识到你的受害者心态是你应该进去并杀死你所有脆弱能力的东西。你不需要社区。你需要能够作为一个完全
individualistic person, motivated by rational self-interest until you don't feel anything at all anymore. And this new generation, you know, that's coming up, they don't even know what questions to ask. They've been trained in a therapy that's stripped of its own history and they learn evidence-based practices without understanding that the evidence is based on what the therapist who knew things that they didn't know. And it's like teaching surgery by showing somebody how to hold a scalpel but never explaining anatomy. They can go through motions but they can't know what they're cutting and they can't recognize the different tensions and the viscous energy against
个人主义的人运作，受理性自身利益驱动，直到你再也感觉不到任何东西。而这新一代，你知道，正在成长起来的人，他们甚至不知道该问什么问题。他们接受了一种剥离了自身历史的治疗训练，他们学习循证实践，却不理解证据是基于那些知道他们所不知道的事情的治疗师。这就像通过向某人展示如何握住手术刀但从不解释解剖学来教授外科手术。他们可以走过场，但他们不知道自己在切什么，他们无法识别不同的张力和对抗的粘性能量。
the blade. The most rational era in history became the most irrational, the most scientific approach created by the most unscientific outcomes, and the culture that banished metaphor took everything literally. The society that deleted feelings became entirely driven by them. And we solved our problem of consciousness by pretending it didn't exist. We solved the problem of trauma by making it unspeakable, and we solved the problem of depth by staying on the surface. And we solved the problem of the soul by declaring that it was dead. And just as an aside, like if anyone's listening to this series and they think that I'm advocating for some lack of accountability or objectivity in the therapy room, that I'm telling therapists to just follow their hearts or do whatever pseudoscience they want to make up and pretend it works, you've missed the point. I'm asking you to ground things in an idea
利刃。历史上最理性的时代变成了最非理性的时代，最科学的方法创造出了最不科学的结果，而摒弃隐喻的文化将一切都字面化了。删除情感的社会最终完全被情感所驱动。我们通过假装意识不存在来解决意识问题。我们通过让创伤变得无法言说来解决创伤问题，通过停留在表面来解决深度问题。我们通过宣布灵魂已死来解决灵魂问题。顺便说一句，如果有人在听这个系列节目，并认为我是在提倡治疗室里缺乏问责制或客观性，认为我是在告诉治疗师只管追随内心，或者编造任何伪科学并假装它有效，那你就误解了我的意思。我要求的是将事物建立在一个理念之上
that may not validate in a two-week study, but that you actually have to go out and find real patterns, real wisdom, real results, not just the kind that fit in a spreadsheet. And one of the biggest lessons from the satanic panic is this cycle that America keeps repeating. When two groups make this uneasy alliance, in this case evangelicals, conservative Catholics, and Reagan's hyper-capitalist, you know, neocons, with this feminist social workers that are trying to do somatic and social therapy, when it all blows up, when the ideas are proven wrong, or when someone gets embarrassed, when people get made fools of, the people with the actual power are never held accountable. fools of, the people with the actual power are never held accountable. It wasn't social workers that did the satanic panic. It wasn't feminists that benefited from it. It wasn't them that needed to platform these things. They were just trying to help people. And
这个理念可能无法在为期两周的研究中得到验证，但你实际上必须走出去寻找真实的模式、真实的智慧、真实的结果，而不仅仅是那些适合电子表格的结果。撒旦恐慌带来的最大教训之一就是美国不断重复的这种循环。当两个群体结成这种不安的联盟时——在这种情况下是福音派、保守派天主教徒和里根的超资本主义新保守派——与那些试图进行躯体和社交治疗的女权主义社会工作者结盟，当一切爆发时，当这些想法被证明是错误时，或者当有人感到尴尬时，当人们被愚弄时，真正拥有权力的人却从未被追究责任。并不是社会工作者制造了撒旦恐慌。并不是女权主义者从中受益。并不是他们需要为这些事情提供平台。他们只是想帮助别人。而
I'm not going to defend the things that some of those social workers and some of those therapists did wrong or did ignorantly. But the satanic panic is always used by people, even psychotherapists, who's writing I respect to advocate for science is this hyper-empirical model that can create the most perfect therapy or has at CBT. But here's the thing, it wasn't social workers who had power. It wasn't the feminists, it wasn't the lefties. Every single time that there's a lesson to be learned, the people with the power pick a scapegoat from anyone foolish enough to trust them.
我不会为那些社会工作者和治疗师所做的一些错误或无知的事情辩护。但撒旦恐慌总是被人们——甚至是那些我尊重其写作的心理治疗师——用来倡导科学，将其作为一种可以创造最完美治疗或认知行为疗法（CBT）的超经验模型。但问题是，拥有权力的并不是社会工作者。不是女权主义者，也不是左派。每一次有教训可学时，掌权者都会从任何愚蠢到信任他们的人中挑选替罪羊。
And during this time, Reagan is running clandestine operations around the world. The CIA was trafficking children and running drugs. A lot of this is declassified and not conspiracy, and a whole lot more of it is implied by what we don't know. And the Catholic Church was covering up systematic sexual abuse while using the Satanic Panic to prove that the devil was real. Multiple conservative and neoliberal senators later er outed as sexual abusers who were throwing aspersions at teenagers listening to punk rock and platforming the Satanic Panic because they needed it.
在此期间，里根在世界各地进行秘密行动。中央情报局在贩运儿童和走私毒品。其中很多已经解密，并非阴谋论，还有更多内容隐含在我们所不知道的事情中。天主教会掩盖了系统的性虐待，同时利用撒旦恐慌来证明魔鬼是真实存在的。多位保守派和新自由主义参议员后来被曝光是性虐待者，他们指责听朋克摇滚的青少年，并为撒旦恐慌提供平台，因为他们需要它。
Not because the patients did, and not because the therapists did. Because the broader culture that held power Needed it to be that way when they all lined up to attack hippies who were just trying to create genuine community as this made up risk and The risks of making humans into machines is that we can't see ourselves as networks anymore But here's where the computer network might actually work as a metaphor We are networks. Relational psychotherapy works because family dynamics become internalized psychological
不是因为病人需要，也不是因为治疗师需要。因为掌握权力的更广泛的文化需要它成为那样。当他们排队攻击那些只是试图创造真正社区的嬉皮士时，将其视为一种虚构的风险。将人类变成机器的风险在于，我们无法再将自己视为网络。但计算机网络在这里可能确实是一个有效的隐喻。我们就是网络。关系心理治疗之所以有效，是因为家庭动态变成了内在的心理
systems. As the world becomes hyperconnected and hyperindustrialized, people feel these neural networks unconsciously. And when you see a men's rights influencer spreading poison online, what you're seeing is someone probing across networks to find weak spots, to find vulnerable people, colonizing vulnerable areas. In this case, it's young men with no upward mobility and often no father to speak of. And you have to look at the material forces that created these realities instead of demonizing these people. They're just exploiting the world that we built.
系统。随着世界变得高度互联和高度工业化，人们潜意识里感受到了这些神经网络。当你看到一个男性权利影响者在网上散布毒素时，你看到的是有人在跨网络探测弱点，寻找脆弱的人，殖民脆弱的领域。在这种情况下，是那些没有向上流动机会、往往没有父亲的年轻男性。你必须审视创造这些现实的物质力量，而不是妖魔化这些人。他们只是在利用我们建立的世界。
And I'm not defending them either. But if you don't want to look at the forces underneath them, I'm looking at you. The mind, when we see it as neural networks, as forms of interconnected representation outside itself, you know, when the mind that sees networks, opportunities for expansion, it tries to creep outside of itself. And Jung was far more prepared for this inevitable technological metaphor than Freud or Beck. People like Marshall McLuhan or Bowen from the early media
我也不是在为他们辩护。但如果你不想审视他们背后的力量，那我就在审视你。当我们把心灵视为神经网络，视为自身之外的互联表征形式时，你知道，当心灵看到网络、看到扩张的机会时，它会试图爬出自身。荣格比弗洛伊德或贝克更适合这种不可避免的技术隐喻。像马歇尔·麦克卢汉或来自早期媒体
and digital analysis movement in the 60s and 70s. They were saying that God is gonna be a network for years or that society is going to enter network in a way that we don't even, we become less than individual. But we still think that we're individuals and that will create this problem if we're not aware of it. And our projections collectively participate in that network. So when I say trust your intuition, I don't mean make things up. I don't mean just go in and say whatever shit you want to say.
和数字分析运动的鲍文在60年代和70年代就说过，上帝多年来一直是一个网络，或者说社会将以一种我们甚至无法察觉的方式进入网络，我们变得不再是个体。但我们仍然认为自己是个体，如果我们不意识到这一点，就会产生这个问题。我们的集体投射参与了那个网络。所以当我建议相信直觉时，我并不是说要编造东西。我不是说让你进去随便说你想说的废话。
I mean understand that we are networked beings reading networked realities. The patterns that you're sensing might not show up in a controlled study because they are network effects, not individual symptoms. And the accountability that I'm calling for is this. Stop letting the powerful rewrite history every time their alliances blow up. Stop letting them scapegoat the healers while they run the world into the ground. Stop pretending that CBT is scientific when it's just capitalism wearing a lab coat. Real science stays curious. Real healing works within networks, not just individuals. Real accountability means naming who actually has power and what they are doing with it. That's not anti-science, that's actual science.
我的意思是理解我们是阅读网络现实的网络化存在。你感知到的模式可能不会出现在对照研究中，因为它们是网络效应，而不是个体症状。我所呼吁的问责制是这样的：别再让掌权者在他们的联盟破裂时重写历史。别再让他们在把世界搞得一团糟时把治疗师当作替罪羊。别再假装CBT是科学，它只是穿着白大褂的资本主义。真正的科学保持好奇心。真正的治愈在网络中起作用，而不仅仅是个体。真正的问责意味着指名道姓地指出谁真正拥有权力以及他们用它做了什么。那不是反科学，那是真正的科学。
And that includes all the data. Even the parts that make the powerful uncomfortable. And even the parts that are inconvenient to the profit motive, which are the parts that the, you know, I love science people want to throw away. Here's a pretty common experience that is described to me by people that have been in CBT before they come to my office. The client says, I think that trauma is stored in my body. I notice that my body does this when and they're cut off. That's just anxiety. Let's work on your thought patterns. Point to the emotion on the wheel. Rate your distress from 1 to 10. But I can feel it in my throat and those are
这包括所有数据。即使是那些让掌权者感到不舒服的部分。甚至包括那些对利润动机不便的部分，而这些正是那些所谓的“我热爱科学”的人想要抛弃的部分。以下是人们在来到我的办公室之前接受过CBT治疗后向我描述的一种非常普遍的经历。客户说：“我认为创伤储存在我的身体里。我注意到我的身体在……时会这样。”然后他们被打断了。“那只是焦虑。让我们处理你的思维模式。指出轮盘上的情绪。给你的痛苦程度从1到10打分。”“但我能在喉咙里感觉到它，那些是
cognitive distortions. Here's a worksheet. Point to the emotion on the wheel and realize that it is not logical. But I notice that my throat does this thing like I'm trying to stop. That's a victim mindset. You're trying to make an excuse instead of a solution. Do you want the next day to be different than the rest of your life? Do you want the next day to be different than the last couple days have been? They cut you off, they intervene, or worse, they don't cut you off and they listen to you and they don't believe you and the patient picks up on that energy. And a lot of these young therapists like they genuinely believe that they're helping, they're doing exactly what they were trained to do, they just have no idea that their training is missing
认知扭曲。这是一张工作表。指出轮盘上的情绪，并意识到它是不合逻辑的。”“但我注意到我的喉咙有这种感觉，就像我在试图阻止什么。”“那是受害者心态。你在试图找借口而不是寻找解决方案。你想让明天和你的余生不同吗？你想让明天和过去几天不同吗？”他们打断你，他们干预，或者更糟的是，他们不打断你，他们听你说话，但他们不相信你，病人会感受到那种能量。许多年轻的治疗师真诚地相信他们在提供帮助，他们正在做他们受训时被要求做的事情，他们只是不知道他们的训练缺失了
90% of what makes therapy work. And the client leaves with a prescription, you know, worksheets in their bag and they feel unheard and they start to think, some of them, that the thing that was unheard must be unimportant. And they'll try another therapist and then another and looking for something that they can't name because the language for it has been deleted. And there are fewer and fewer versions of the thing that they really need out there for them to find. And so fewer and fewer people find it and fewer and fewer people start to trust that thing of self, that part of self, their vulnerability, their capacity for somatic emotion. And just like Freud and Jung,
90%使治疗有效的东西。客户带着处方离开，包里装着工作表，他们感到未被倾听，于是开始认为，其中一些人认为，那个未被倾听的事情一定是不重要的。他们会尝试另一个治疗师，然后又一个，寻找他们无法命名的事物，因为它的语言已经被删除了。他们能找到的真正需要的东西的版本越来越少。因此，找到它的人越来越少，开始信任那种自我、那部分自我、他们的脆弱性、他们躯体情感能力的人也越来越少。就像弗洛伊德和荣格一样，
they're not heard by their dad, or they're not heard from wherever that wound came from. And the wound becomes invisible, and then it becomes a part of identity. And then it becomes something I can't change. Meanwhile, in a community clinic across town, there's a 72-year-old therapist trained in the 1970s who sees her last patient of the day and she bills insurance for CBT for depression but what happens in the room is something else entirely, something that can't
他们没有被父亲倾听，或者他们没有从那个伤口来源的地方得到倾听。伤口变得隐形，然后成为身份的一部分。然后它变成了一种我无法改变的东西。与此同时，在城另一头的社区诊所里，有一位72岁的治疗师，她在70年代受训，她接待了当天最后一位病人，她为抑郁症的CBT向保险公司开具账单，但房间里发生的事情完全是另一回事，那是无法
be manualized, measured, or taught in six weeks. And she listens with her whole body and she feels the unsaid hovering in the air and she holds the unbearable until it becomes bearable. She does the thing that has no name anymore because we've forgotten the names. And when I meet one of these people I know who they saw last because I can see it in an impression of how they think about themselves and how they think about trauma and how they talk and how they engage with me. And when it's the first type of patient I am so sad.
被手册化、测量或在六周内教授的东西。她用全身去倾听，她感受到了空气中悬浮的未言之语，她承载着那无法忍受的，直到它变得可以忍受。她做着那件不再有名字的事情，因为我们已经忘记了名字。当我遇到这些人中的一个时，我知道他们最后见的是谁，因为我能从他们看待自己、看待创伤、谈话以及与我互动的方式中看到印记。当那是第一种类型的病人时，我感到非常悲伤。
And when it's the first type of patient, I am so sad. Rosenhand's three words became prophecy. Empty, hollow, thud. But here's the thing. Even with these incentive structures, even with this systematic hell, you can't kill something like a perennial philosophy. Because it becomes its own kind of evidence-based practice. The fact that these ideas that are timeless and that existed before the 60s and the 70s and the 80s continue to resurge across cultures, across time, across people who didn't know each other, who didn't talk, who had no interaction,
当那是第一种类型的病人时，我感到非常悲伤。罗森汉的三词成了预言。空洞、虚无、沉闷。但问题是，即使有这些激励结构，即使有这种系统的地狱，你也无法扼杀像永恒哲学这样的东西。因为它成为了它自己的一种循证实践。事实上，这些永恒的、在60年代、70年代和80年代之前就存在的思想，在不同的文化、不同的时间、在那些互不相识、没有交谈、没有任何互动的人群中持续复苏，
that independently discovered the same things. That itself is a kind of evidence. The soul will remind you that it exists. And even with these incentives, there are people doing wonderful work and making discoveries. The resistance blooms in the cracks of the machine. Hernando de Soto done a great big hollow. In the bottom of a cave took the location to his grave. In the valley that they flooded.
独立地发现了同样的事情。这本身就是一种证据。灵魂会提醒你它的存在。即使有这些激励措施，仍然有人在做着出色的工作并取得发现。抵抗在机器的裂缝中绽放。埃尔南多·德·索托在洞穴底部挖了一个大坑，把位置带进了坟墓。在他们淹没的山谷里。
Treasure he stole, cold-blooded, at the bottom of a lake. The economy at stake, he melted forgotten gods of old into forgotten bars of gold. The TVA dammed up all the land To help the common man Who are these gods that glitter in the night? So full of us and so full of light Are we each alone in the dark? I see the fire, where is the spark? Danger will rob and sun Your journey has just begun
他偷走的宝藏，冷血地，在湖底。经济岌岌可危，他把被遗忘的古神熔化成被遗忘的金条。田纳西河谷管理局筑坝拦水，为了帮助普通人。这些在夜里闪闪发光的众神是谁？如此充满我们，如此充满光芒。我们是否都在黑暗中孤独一人？我看到了火，火花在哪里？危险会抢劫太阳，你的旅程才刚刚开始
Into a place beyond knowing Are we missing an oaring? What did we hope to find about ourselves? Holding desperately onto God's lapels Twist the stars in space To constellate into a face Long after your eyes adjust There is still no one here but us In the midst of parts unknown
进入一个超越认知的领域。我们是否漏掉了一只桨？我们希望发现关于自己的什么？绝望地抓住上帝的翻领。扭曲空间中的星星，聚集成一张脸。在你的眼睛适应很久之后，这里除了我们仍然空无一人。在未知部分的中间，
We are still running from our home Is the universe some lonely scream? Or is it all, all part of his dream? Physics is rules that collide We can only measure it from inside Alexander the Great was afraid to be late Descended from Zeus He had to prove he couldn't lose Still afraid to eat our shadow We chase after El Dorado Odin gave a tree his eye To know the reason why Hanging on the wood he begged us to be good In the helpless authority of God
我们仍在逃离家园。宇宙是一声孤独的尖叫吗？还是这一切，都是他梦的一部分？物理学是碰撞的规则，我们只能从内部测量它。亚历山大大帝害怕迟到，作为宙斯的后裔，他必须证明自己不会输。仍然害怕吃掉我们的影子，我们追逐着黄金国。奥丁把一只眼睛献给了一棵树，为了知道原因。挂在木头上，他乞求我们要善良。在上帝无助的权威中，
Spare the child and spoil the rod Make dust to be good in the helpless authority of God Spare the child and spoil the rod Outer world is only what's inside All the same age in the labyrinth In the garden breathing hyacinth You only fight what you hide There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
爱子如杀子。在上帝无助的权威中，为了善良而制造尘埃。爱子如杀子。外部世界只是内部的投射。在迷宫中都是同龄人。在花园里呼吸着风信子。你只与你隐藏的东西战斗。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。